When you're with Amex Platinum, you get access to exclusive dining experiences and an annual travel credit. So the best tapas in town might be in a new town altogether. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at Amex.ca. this episode is brought to you by Defender with a towing capacity of 3,500 kilograms and a weighting depth of 900 millimeters, the Defender 110 pushes what's possible. Learn more at
当您使用美国运通白金卡时，您将获得独家餐饮体验和年度旅行积分。所以城里最好的塔帕斯餐厅可能就在另一个全新的城市。这就是美国运通强大的后盾。适用条款和条件。详情请访问 Amex.ca。本集由 Defender 赞助，Defender 拥有 3,500 公斤的牵引能力和 900 毫米的涉水深度，Defender 110 突破了无限可能。了解更多信息，请访问
land rover.ca. We have some fun merch news. Yes. We are back with a limited time pop-up Birch store. Yes, and we have brand new Office Ladies merch for you. It is available September 3rd through September 17th. We've got some classic designs that we know you love, plus an all-new Scranton Hot collection. We also have a super cute Finer Things Club tote and a water bottle that says Office Ladies, Sassy since 2019. So if you've been waiting for new Office Ladies merch for yourself, your best friend, your sister, your mom, your hubby, now's your chance. Head to shopofficeladies.com and get your order in today. Hello and welcome to your second drink of cocktails.
land rover.ca。我们有一些有趣的周边新闻。是的。我们带着限时快闪周边商店回来了。没错，我们为您准备了全新的《办公室女郎》周边商品。销售时间为 9 月 3 日至 9 月 17 日。我们有一些您一定会喜欢的经典设计，还有全新的“斯克兰顿热辣”系列。我们还有一个超级可爱的“精致事物俱乐部”手提袋和一个印有“办公室女郎，自 2019 年起就很时髦”字样的水瓶。所以，如果您一直期待为自己、最好的朋友、姐妹、妈妈或丈夫购买新的《办公室女郎》周边，现在就是机会。前往 shopofficeladies.com，今天就下单吧。你好，欢迎来到您的第二杯鸡尾酒。
Okay, lady, I'm going to jump right in here. Okay. There were two things from this episode that we got a ton of mail about after this episode of the podcast aired. All right. And I know that you like titling things. I do. So one of them I'm calling Mystery Solved, and the other one is New Mystery Opened.
好的，女士，我要直接切入正题了。好的。这一集播出后，我们收到了大量关于其中两件事的邮件。好的。我知道你喜欢给事情起标题。我确实喜欢。所以其中一个我称之为“谜题解开”，另一个我称之为“新谜题开启”。
I am intrigued. So you might remember when we were breaking down this episode, I became slightly obsessed with like this creepy ghost lady that I spotted in the background of Michael's talking head at the party. I remember. And so many people wrote in. And this is a mystery solved. Mindy S. said, my husband and I figured out what the blonde wig-looking thing was behind Michael Scott when he was doing his talking head. It's the back of someone preparing food. You can see them moving if you watch really carefully. Michael is standing in front of the doorway to the kitchen. Maybe it's
我很好奇。你可能还记得我们在解析这一集时，我对我在迈克尔聚会上的谈话头背景中发现的那个令人毛骨悚然的幽灵女士有点着迷。我记得。很多人写信来。这是一个解开的谜题。Mindy S. 说，我和我丈夫弄清楚了迈克尔·斯科特在进行谈话头采访时，他身后那个看起来像金色假发的东西是什么。那是某人准备食物的背影。如果你仔细看，你可以看到他们在移动。迈克尔站在厨房门口前。也许是
one of the caterers. Oh, that makes sense. And Allison Kay said they are wearing a red shirt like the servers. It's totally a blonde server with her back to the camera. but I do agree she looks creepy. And Jackie J. said, I found the ghost. It's a server. You can see her with a tray earlier in the episode when Jan is dragging Michael to the bathroom around 14 minutes. All right then.
其中一位餐饮服务员。哦，这说得通。Allison Kay 说他们穿着像服务员一样的红色衬衫。那绝对是一个背对着镜头的金发服务员。但我确实同意她看起来很吓人。Jackie J. 说，我找到了那个幽灵。那是个服务员。在这一集早些时候，当简拖着迈克尔去洗手间时，大约 14 分钟处，你可以看到她拿着托盘。好吧。
Mystery solved. Thanks you guys for writing in. But I'm really curious. What is your mystery now opened? Well, we also got a ton of mail like this one from Lana W. So I just rewatched for the 48th time. The cocktails. 18th. And I noticed that Jan arrives at David Wallace's house in her car, but at the end,
谜题解开。谢谢你们写信来。但我真的很好奇。你现在开启的谜题是什么？嗯，我们也收到了很多像 Lana W. 这样的邮件。所以我刚刚第 48 次重看了《鸡尾酒》这一集。第 18 次。我注意到简是开车来到大卫·华莱士家的，但在最后，
she and Michael are on their way home after the dinner, and she is in his car with Dwight hiding in the back. Where is her car? Where did they leave it? Right, right, because Jan arrives in her own car. Yeah, and she leaves in Michael's car. Yeah. Like at the beginning, she's even standing at the back of her car and she has her trunk open. Yeah. This is never discussed. I went to the shooting draft. I went to the Peacock Superfan. We never find out why Jan left her car behind. There's no scene that was deleted. There's no discussion. A lot of people wondered like, oh, did she drink too much? And then Michael's driving her home. Yeah. How did she get her car later? Mystery opened. Well, here are my thoughts. Okay. Jan's chapter of life, that is Michael Scott.
她和迈克尔在晚餐后回家的路上，她坐在他的车里，德怀特躲在后面。她的车在哪里？他们把它留在哪里了？对，对，因为简是开着她自己的车来的。是的，她坐迈克尔的车走了。是的。就像在开头，她甚至站在她的车后，后备箱是开着的。是的。这从来没有被讨论过。我查了拍摄草稿。我查了 Peacock 的超级粉丝版。我们从来没有发现简为什么把车留下了。没有被删除的场景。没有讨论。很多人想知道，哦，她是不是喝多了？然后迈克尔开车送她回家。是的。她后来是怎么拿到车的？谜题开启。嗯，这是我的想法。好的。简的人生篇章，也就是迈克尔·斯科特。
She was a hot mess. So I believe that she would have left her car. And, you know, rode with Michael, made that choice. Maybe she's going to go back and get it the next day. I totally buy it. I believe it too. But finally, Angela, while I was looking to solve the Jan Car mystery, I found a really great nugget. I found a season three pitch document.
她当时一团糟。所以我相信她会把车留下，然后，你知道，坐迈克尔的车，做了那个选择。也许她第二天会回去取。我完全相信。我也相信。但最后，安吉拉，当我在试图解开简的车之谜时，我发现了一个非常棒的片段。我发现了一份第三季的提案文件。
Oh, yes, because you would get those. Yes. Oh, give me the scoop. All right. It's keeping with the mystery theme for today. You love the theme. I do. All right.
哦，是的，因为你会收到那些。是的。哦，快告诉我内幕。好的。这符合今天的主题。你喜欢这个主题。我确实喜欢。好的。
This was an episode that was going to be called Pam finds a wallet. I am leaning back with my cup of tea. I cannot wait. Here's what was going to happen. This would have aired during season three. Pam finds a wallet. Okay. Someone asked her where she found it.
这一集原本打算叫《帕姆捡到一个钱包》。我靠在椅子上，喝着茶。我等不及了。这就是将要发生的事情。这本应在第三季播出。《帕姆捡到一个钱包》。好的。有人问她是在哪里捡到的。
She said that she found it while she was on a run. Pam is a runner? This is what, listen to this. Pam would have a talking head where she says when I told people I ran I couldn't tell what their judgmental attitude
她说她是在跑步时捡到的。帕姆是个跑步者？这就是，听着。帕姆会有一个谈话头，她说当她告诉别人她跑步时，她看不出他们的评判态度
was either she thinks she's so healthy or she doesn't look like she jogs. So it's revealed that the wallet belongs to a man and there's no money
是什么，要么她认为自己很健康，要么她看起来不像会慢跑的人。然后揭露钱包属于一个男人，钱包里没有钱，
in the wallet but she spreads out all the contents on her desk. There's his license, credit cards, business cards and then people come over
但她把所有东西都摊在桌子上。有他的驾照、信用卡、名片，然后人们走过来，
and they're just ooing and eyeing over it because in his driver's license photo he's very handsome he's 30. He lives in a nice part of town. I can only imagine the hubbub though at an office like Dunder Mifflin. Not a lot of fun stuff happens throughout the day. Nothing to really like get you
他们只是对着它发出惊叹，因为在他的驾照照片里，他非常英俊，他 30 岁。他住在城里不错的地方。我只能想象在像邓德·米夫林这样的办公室里会引起多大的骚动。白天没发生什么有趣的事。没什么能真正让你
going. All of a sudden just like, oh, mystery man wallet. Yes. And then from his birthday on his license, people find out his astrological sign. Oh my gosh. And they're like, oh, Pam, he's so compatible with you. And then Karen keeps saying, that is one fine looking man. Because she's really trying to push Pam away from Jim, you know? Right, right. So people in the office start believing that this is Pam's great soulmate. This is people who are so bored. Look what they've done.
兴奋起来的。突然间，就像，哦，神秘男人的钱包。是的。然后根据他驾照上的生日，人们发现了他的星座。天哪。他们说，哦，帕姆，他和你是绝配。然后凯伦一直说，那真是一个帅气的男人。因为她真的想把帕姆从吉姆身边推开，你知道吗？对，对。所以办公室里的人开始相信这是帕姆的灵魂伴侣。这些人太无聊了。看看他们做了什么。
They've now spun this into Pam's soulmate. Mm-hmm. And despite herself, Pam gets a little excited. So she Googles him and she calls him. And he's this very nice, funny person. And he says, oh, my gosh, it's going to be impossible for me to leave my office. Could you just FedEx the wallet to me? or maybe he can pick it up in a couple of days.
他们现在把它编成了帕姆的灵魂伴侣。嗯哼。尽管帕姆自己也觉得有点兴奋。所以她谷歌了一下他，并给他打了电话。他是一个非常好、风趣的人。他说，天哪，我很难离开办公室。你能把钱包快递给我吗？或者也许他可以在几天后去取。
But here's what it said. It said, Pam takes a beat and we see her be a little brave. And she says, no, she can drop it off for him. She lies and says it's on her way home. And then in a talking head, she'll say, it's actually on the other side of town, but you never know. So the whole office has this big send-off for her because they know she's going to go drop off the wallet.
但这就是它上面写的。它说，帕姆停顿了一下，我们看到她变得勇敢了一点。她说，不，她可以顺路送过去。她撒谎说这在她回家的路上。然后在谈话头里，她说，其实是在城的另一边，但你永远不知道。所以整个办公室为她举行了盛大的欢送会，因为他们知道她要去送钱包。
Before she leaves, Dwight demands that she give him information so he can tell the police where to go find her body. Classic Dwight. Yes. And when she gets to the house, this very handsome guy opens the door and he's friendly and he's sweet. And then he opens the wallet and he says there was $200 in here. Where is it? Oh, no. And Pam says, oh, I'm sorry. There was nothing in there. And he is going to say to her, you know, you probably want a reward. I was going to give you the money in the wallet. But since you have it already, I guess I don't need to. Oh, no. I know. And then finally, his girlfriend walks into frame. This is horrible. It's a total crash and burn, but Pam goes back to the office, and she lies. She's going to tell everybody it went really, really well because she's embarrassed. That's Pam finds a wallet.
在她离开之前，德怀特要求她提供信息，这样他就可以告诉警察去哪里找她的尸体。典型的德怀特。是的。当她到达房子时，这个非常英俊的男人打开门，他很友好，很甜。然后他打开钱包说，这里面有 200 美元。它在哪儿？哦，不。帕姆说，哦，对不起。里面什么都没有。他会对她说，你知道，你可能想要奖励。我本来打算把钱包里的钱给你的。但既然你已经拿到了，我想我不需要了。哦，不。我知道。最后，他的女朋友走进了画面。这太可怕了。这完全是一场灾难，但帕姆回到了办公室，她撒谎了。她要告诉大家一切都进行得非常顺利，因为她很尴尬。这就是《帕姆捡到一个钱包》。
I would have watched that. It's so cute, right? There's so many hills and valleys to that. I know. It really reminds me when I worked, you know, as a temp and also just as an operator, you know, in the call center, you would get bored. And if anything out of the ordinary happened, like there was a new like UPS guy. We had the same guy at the call center for so long. And then one day there was a new guy and they're like, new guy, new guy. What's his story? What happened to the old guy? And people started
我会看那一集的。太可爱了，对吧？那里面有太多的起伏了。我知道。这真的让我想起我工作的时候，你知道，作为临时工，也作为接线员，你知道，在呼叫中心，你会感到无聊。如果发生任何不寻常的事情，比如有一个新的 UPS 快递员。我们在呼叫中心有同一个快递员很久了。然后有一天来了一个新人，他们说，新人，新人。他的故事是什么？旧的那个怎么了？人们开始
spinning out. Maybe old guy, I don't know. Did he have a heart attack? What happened to him? Is he on vacation? Did he get a divorce? Like people started like writing a whole story. Why new guy? And it was just like, literally like he had taken the day to get a root canal or something. It was like the most mundane thing. Exactly. Well, I loved all of that lady. And just a reminder to everyone listening that this Wednesday, we are breaking down the pilot episode of the paper. And the first four episodes are out now on Peacock. Yes. Spoiler alert. We loved it. We can't wait to share all about it. All right. And now here is your second drink of cocktails. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey we were on the office together and we're best friends and now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you we're the office ladies hello everyone hi there do you have your drink ready did you pour a drink because today we're talking about talking about cocktails. I should have. Dang it. Why are we not drinking right now? That's a whole other podcast. Angela, do you want to tell everyone where you are right now? Yes, you guys. Okay, so the
胡思乱想。也许旧的那个，我不知道。他心脏病发作了吗？他怎么了？他在度假吗？他离婚了吗？人们开始编造整个故事。为什么是新人？其实就像，他只是花了一天时间去根管治疗什么的。这就像最平凡的事情。完全正确。好吧，我喜欢这一切，女士。提醒一下所有听众，这个星期三，我们将解析《办公室》的试播集。前四集现在已经在 Peacock 上线了。是的。剧透警告。我们很喜欢它。我们迫不及待地想分享关于它的一切。好的，现在这是您的第二杯鸡尾酒。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛，我们一起出演了《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友，现在我们正在为您制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女郎》。大家好，你们好。你们准备好喝的了吗？你们倒酒了吗？因为今天我们要谈论的是鸡尾酒。我应该倒的。该死。为什么我们现在不喝酒？那是另一个播客了。安吉拉，你想告诉大家你现在在哪里吗？是的，伙计们。好的，所以
internet at my house is L. Krobski. And can I say L. Krobski? That's so weird. I think you can. We've said worse. So the internet at my house is really bad. And apparently we're in an area that doesn't even qualify for a real upgrade like we've called and they're like yeah no it's not available there and I'm like what are you talking about so um anyway I just well I just did not have a great system I tried Jenna I really tried for months for months yeah and what you guys haven't seen is I would just be zooming with Jenna and then I just get the boot for like 45 minutes um yeah and then people are always like why don't you guys just do a video version of your podcast just throw it on up there. And I'm like, well, if you want to see 45 minutes of Angela cursing and disappearing and coming back, we're happy to throw it on up for you.
我家的互联网是 L. Krobski。我能说 L. Krobski 吗？那太奇怪了。我想你可以。我们说过更糟的。所以我家的互联网真的很差。显然我们所在的地区甚至没有资格进行真正的升级，就像我们打电话过去，他们说，是的，不，那里没有，我就说，你在说什么。所以，嗯，无论如何，我只是，我只是没有一个好的系统。我试过了，珍娜，我真的试了几个月，几个月。是的，你们没看到的是，我会和珍娜进行 Zoom 会议，然后我就会被踢出去 45 分钟。嗯，是的，然后人们总是说，为什么你们不做一个视频版的播客，直接放上去。我说，好吧，如果你想看 45 分钟安吉拉咒骂、消失又回来的视频，我们很乐意为你放上去。
Sam said his favorite was when Mindy was a guest. I got booted off three times. And he said he could hear on my audio track. You and Mindy were talking. And I was just going, mother. So, yes. But also, Angela, you would be frozen. And then Mindy and I would be frozen. And then Mindy and I would. wouldn't really know if you were there or not. And so we would throw to you, we'd be like, right, Ange? Oh, I don't think she's there. No. She's not responding. She's not moving. So I am really excited today, I guess, just me in one room, Sam in another room. And I guess Conan O'Brien is coming later. Oh, he canceled. So it's just me and Sam. It's just me and Sam here today. And when I saw Sam, I thought I was going to cry because it was just so fun to see him in person rather than just hearing him.
萨姆说他最喜欢的是明迪做嘉宾的那一集。我被踢出去了三次。他说他能在我的音轨上听到。你和明迪在说话。而我只是在说，天哪。所以，是的。但安吉拉，你也会冻结。然后明迪和我也会冻结。然后明迪和我，不会真的知道你在不在。所以我们会转向你，我们会说，对吧，安吉？哦，我不认为她在那里。不。她没有回应。她没有动。所以我今天真的很兴奋，我想，只是我在一个房间，萨姆在另一个房间。我想柯南·奥布莱恩稍后会来。哦，他取消了。所以只有我和萨姆。今天只有我和萨姆在这里。当我看到萨姆时，我以为我会哭，因为亲眼见到他而不是只听到他的声音真是太有趣了。
Well, it's really cool for me to see you in the studio. It's making me very homesick. I know. And then I have my mask and we have sanitizer and you guys, we're figuring it out. We're figuring it out how to safely return to work. And that gives me hope. Yeah. And I know a lot of y'all out there are doing this.
嗯，在演播室见到你对我来说真的很酷。这让我非常想家。我知道。然后我有我的口罩，我们有消毒液，伙计们，我们正在想办法。我们正在想办法如何安全地重返工作岗位。这给了我希望。是的。我知道你们很多人都在这样做。
I know my sister, you know, my sister's a nurse and one of my sisters works for the phone company and she gave me a real lecture on Wi-Fi. And what I apparently don't have, you guys, there's this thing. It's like the holy grail of Wi-Fi, Jenna, I think you know what it's called. It's like gamer Wi-Fi. Yeah, you get a gamer modem, and it can just handle a lot. And we got it because, you know, we're trying to make a podcast while both of my kids are Zooming school. So to have three of us on the system, the guy came by to install it.
我知道我姐姐，你知道，我姐姐是护士，我其中一个姐姐在电话公司工作，她给了我一个关于 Wi-Fi 的讲座。显然我没有，伙计们，有这个东西。这就像 Wi-Fi 的圣杯，珍娜，我想你知道它叫什么。这就像游戏玩家 Wi-Fi。是的，你买一个游戏调制解调器，它就能处理很多事情。我们买了它，因为，你知道，我们正在尝试制作播客，而我的两个孩子都在 Zoom 上课。所以我们三个人都在系统上，那个人过来安装它。
and he had this little like thing that shows you the strength of your signal. He looked at my husband. He goes, you guys really don't get much of a signal here. And we're like, yeah, we know. We're aware. It's why you're here. At least it's available in your area, Jenna. And it's available in our area.
他有一个小东西可以显示你的信号强度。他看着我丈夫。他说，你们在这里真的收不到什么信号。我们说，是的，我们知道。我们意识到了。这就是你在这里的原因。至少在你的地区有这个服务，珍娜。在我们的地区也有。
Well, now we need to get you gamer headphones and we need to get you a gamer chair. Have you seen they have these special gamer chairs? Oh, it would make me really happy to see you sitting in one. Are we ever going to talk about the episode today? I don't know. God, yes. Maybe we shouldn't. What are we here for? Oh, my God. 20 minutes later. It is cocktails, you guys. Season 3, episode 17. It is written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by J.J. Abrams. Here's a quick summary. Michael and Jan go public with their relationship when they attend a party at David Wallace's home.
好吧，现在我们需要给你买游戏耳机，我们需要给你买一把游戏椅。你见过他们有这些特别的游戏椅吗？哦，看到你坐在上面会让我很高兴。我们今天还要谈论这一集吗？我不知道。天哪，是的。也许我们不应该。我们来这里是为了什么？天哪。20 分钟后。是鸡尾酒，伙计们。第三季，第 17 集。由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，J.J. 艾布拉姆斯执导。这是一个简短的总结。迈克尔和简在参加大卫·华莱士家的聚会时公开了他们的关系。
The CFO, not his initials common mistake. Everyone else in the office goes out for Happy Hour. And Pam tells Roy about her and Jim. Oh, Pam. Pam. Not Pammy, but Pam. Don't call me Pammy. Don't call her Pammy.
首席财务官，不是他的首字母缩写，常见的错误。办公室里的其他人出去参加欢乐时光。帕姆告诉罗伊关于她和吉姆的事。哦，帕姆。帕姆。不是帕米，是帕姆。别叫我帕米。别叫她帕米。
I bet you have some fast facts. Fast fact number one. This is a fan question from Scott F. Eladio Ben and Abby Kellner. How was J.J. Abrams tabby. to direct, right? J.J. Abrams. Directed this. Freaking Abrams. You guys, Google him. He's done everything. We could not believe he was coming to our little show. Now, this was before he directed Star Wars, but Angela, still. Still. Does it freak you out that Star Wars guy directed
我打赌你有一些快讯。快讯第一条。这是一个来自斯科特·F、埃拉迪奥·本和艾比·凯尔纳的粉丝问题。J.J. 艾布拉姆斯执导怎么样？J.J. 艾布拉姆斯。执导了这一集。该死的艾布拉姆斯。伙计们，谷歌一下他。他什么都做过。我们不敢相信他要来我们的小节目。现在，这是在他执导《星球大战》之前，但安吉拉，仍然。仍然。那个《星球大战》的家伙执导了你，这让你感到震惊吗？
you in an episode of The Office? J.J., I know you probably listened to our podcast, faithfully. why wasn't there a very tiny, petite, sassy blonde in your Star Wars movie? Please, just in the background. I don't even have to say anything. Please, can I just be an extra in a Star Wars movie? Please. Yeah. I'll just walk by.
在《办公室》的一集里？J.J.，我知道你可能忠实地听我们的播客。为什么你的《星球大战》电影里没有一个非常娇小、俏皮的金发女郎？求你了，就在背景里。我甚至不需要说什么。求你了，我能当《星球大战》电影里的临时演员吗？求你了。是的。我就走过去。
She'll just walk by. She won't do anything but just walk by. I promise. A tiny blonde comedian is just going to walk on through Star Wars, JJ. No shenanigans. I won't look at camera. I'll look just straight at the ground. I hope he hears this.
她就走过去。她什么都不做，只是走过去。我保证。一个娇小的金发喜剧演员就要走进《星球大战》了，J.J.。没有恶作剧。我不会看镜头。我会直视地面。我希望他听到这个。
Well, listen, guys, so at this point, JJ Abrams was most famous for the TV shows Lost and Alias. Felicity? Felicity. He did Felicity, too? Yes. Wow. I know.
好吧，听着，伙计们，在这一点上，J.J. 艾布拉姆斯最出名的是电视剧《迷失》和《双面女间谍》。《费莉希蒂》？《费莉希蒂》。他也做了《费莉希蒂》？是的。哇。我知道。
That wasn't in my notes. Well, boom. Boom. Well, I think it was just because I was such a huge fan of Lost and alias, the role you didn't get. Thanks for reminding me. I have to tell you, oh my God, this made me laugh so hard. You posted about the Ben Franklin episode and you were like on your Instagram, you're like, and you know, also we talk about the fact that I didn't get the part of Sydney and alias.
那不在我的笔记里。好吧，砰。砰。好吧，我想那只是因为我是《迷失》和《双面女间谍》的超级粉丝，那个你没得到的角色。谢谢你提醒我。我必须告诉你，天哪，这让我笑得太厉害了。你发布了关于本·富兰克林那一集的内容，你在 Instagram 上说，你知道，我们也谈到了我没有得到《双面女间谍》中悉尼那个角色的事实。
Jennifer Gardner went away in and I responded, did you see her post from the beach? Did you see her try to ride that skimmer thing? I mean, come on, lady. I can't believe you are doubling down on this. I did one hour of yoga today very easily. Well, I'll have you know, which basically qualifies me to play a spy on television. Look out community of secret spies. Okay, okay.
詹妮弗·加纳回应了，你看到她从海滩发的帖子了吗？你看到她尝试骑那个滑水板了吗？我的意思是，拜托，女士。我不敢相信你还在坚持这个。我今天做了一个小时的瑜伽，非常轻松。好吧，我要让你知道，这基本上使我有资格在电视上扮演间谍。小心了，秘密间谍社区。好的，好的。
In case you're wondering, I did not confront J.J. Abrams about why I did. not receive the role of Sidney Bristow. Opportunity missed. I let it go. But here's the thing. Here's what happened, guys. He reached out to us about directing an episode. And we were like, yeah.
如果你想知道的话，我没有质问 J.J. 艾布拉姆斯为什么我没有得到悉尼·布里斯托这个角色。错失良机。我放手了。但事情是这样的，伙计们。发生了什么。他联系我们想执导一集。我们当时想，是的。
And we were like, come direct an episode. That's how it happened. We were so giddy, Jenna. We were all so excited. I just remember him being so smiley. Remember how much he smiled? He was like so happy and kind and just energetic. He was so nice. And then, like, I don't know, a few months later, I ran into JJ and his wife at like a fancy, you know, a word show party. And he was like, Angela and like chatted me up. And she was so nice. They're just really nice folks, y'all. Yeah. It's all true. So put me in your stinking Star Wars movie, JJ. Yeah. She just wants to walk by. I just want to walk on. All right. Fast fact number two, lady, I'm calling this one location.
我们当时想，来执导一集吧。事情就是这样发生的。我们当时太兴奋了，珍娜。我们都太兴奋了。我只记得他笑得那么灿烂。记得他笑了多少次吗？他看起来那么快乐、善良，而且充满活力。他太好了。然后，我不知道，几个月后，我在一个高级的颁奖典礼聚会上遇到了 J.J. 和他的妻子。他说，安吉拉，然后和我聊天。她太好了。他们真的是很好的人，伙计们。是的。这一切都是真的。所以把我放进你那该死的《星球大战》电影里吧，J.J.。是的。她只是想走过去。我只是想走过去。好的，快讯第二条，女士，我称之为“地点改变”。
Change. Why are you saying it like that? I don't know. Is it intriguing? Location change. Yeah. Yeah, I'm intrigued. All right, good. Fan question from Anna Carter, B. Smith, Sophia B. Chelsea Lane and Berkeley S. What house was used as David Wallace's home in this episode? Was it the same house used for the inside and the outside? And then we've got additional questions from Mary Roberts, Kelsey Joseph, Zui Wang, Kendall K, and Yvonne A. Hold up. David Wallace's house is a different house than the one used in branch closing. But some of the details are the same. What gives? Here is the answer. Yes, guys, these are good questions because the original house that you saw in branch closing was. was in Pasadena. This is a different house. This one is in Encino.
你为什么那样说？我不知道。这很有趣吗？地点改变。是的。是的，我很感兴趣。好的，很好。来自安娜·卡特、B. 史密斯、索菲亚·B、切尔西·莱恩和伯克利·S 的粉丝问题。这一集中大卫·华莱士的家用了哪栋房子？室内和室外用的是同一栋房子吗？然后我们还有来自玛丽·罗伯茨、凯尔西·约瑟夫、瑞·王、肯德尔·K 和伊冯·A 的额外问题。等等。大卫·华莱士的房子和《分部关闭》中使用的房子不是同一栋。但有些细节是一样的。怎么回事？答案如下。是的，伙计们，这些都是好问题，因为你在《分部关闭》中看到的原始房子是在帕萨迪纳。这是一栋不同的房子。这一栋在恩西诺。
More people wrote in about the house, too, and many people noted that this house has a circular driveway in the front, which is different. We changed the house because J.J. Abrams really liked the interior of this house. So we did dress the front door to match the front door of the Pasadena house. But, yeah, it was a different house. Good eye, good catch. Very good catch, folks. Real good catch. And that makes sense because he would need the interior of the house more than the exterior because the whole episode almost happens in that house. Yeah. And it needed to flow. And there's a lot of moments in this episode where you're on one group of people and then the camera will rack focus and then some other thing is happening in the background. So having that open floor plan inside was really important to the storytelling. I agree. All right. So my next little piece of this fast fact is about poor Richards. We shot poor Richards at the Pickwick Pub, which is inside the Pickwick Bowling Alley in Burbank, California, which is right next to the Pickwick Ice Rink, where we shot Michael's birthday. Well, I have a question for you about this. Because if memory serves, we shot the interior stuff at Pickwick, but that exterior parking lot,
更多人写信询问关于房子的事，许多人注意到这栋房子的前面有一个环形车道，这是不同的。我们换了房子，因为 J.J. 艾布拉姆斯真的很喜欢这栋房子的内部。所以我们确实装饰了前门以匹配帕萨迪纳房子的前门。但是，是的，那是另一栋房子。好眼力，好发现。非常好的发现，伙计们。真的很好的发现。这说得通，因为他需要房子的内部胜过外部，因为几乎整集都发生在那栋房子里。是的。而且它需要流畅。这一集里有很多时刻，你关注一组人，然后摄像机会变焦，然后背景里又发生了别的事情。所以拥有那个开放式的室内平面图对叙事非常重要。我同意。好的。所以我这个快讯的下一小部分是关于“可怜的理查德”。我们在伯班克的 Pickwick 保龄球馆内的 Pickwick 酒吧拍摄了“可怜的理查德”，它就在 Pickwick 溜冰场旁边，我们在那里拍摄了迈克尔的生日。嗯，我有一个关于这个的问题要问你。因为如果记忆没出错，我们在 Pickwick 拍摄了室内部分，但那个室外停车场，
was a different location. Yes. And it was the bar, what's it called? The bar at Oyster House on Moore Park in Studio City. Great. Catch lady. Yes. Yes, lady. I knew what parking lot that was because back in ye oldy improv days when I was
是另一个地点。是的。那是酒吧，叫什么来着？位于影城城 Moore Park 的 Oyster House 的酒吧。好发现，女士。是的。是的，女士。我知道那是哪个停车场，因为在很久以前我表演即兴表演的时候，有时我们会在演出结束后去那里喝一杯庆祝。所以那个停车场区域内的实际酒吧叫 Oyster Bar。它叫 The Bar at Oyster House。哦，我从来没去过。你可以从停车场进入，这就是我们设置它的方式，对吧？或者你可以从街上进入。现在，我有一个快速的问题要问你，因为我知道我们稍后会更多地谈论“可怜的理查德”。
when I was performing long-form improv, sometimes we would go there afterwards for a drink to celebrate our show. So the actual bar that's inside of that parking lot area is called Oyster Bar. It's called The Bar at Oyster House. Oh, I've never been. And you can enter from the parking lot, which is how we sort of set it up, right? Or you can enter from the street. Now, I have a quick question for you because I know we're going to talk more about Poor Richards later.
你去过斯克兰顿真正的“可怜的理查德”吗，安吉拉？是的。你是从停车场进入的吗？是的。它匹配得好吗？还可以。哦，我迫不及待想听更多了。留着以后说。好的，我会留着的。我会留着的。我会留着的。好的，我要带我们进入快讯第三条。女士。什么？你还记得在本·富兰克林那一集时，我们说演员工会提名人来到片场告诉我们我们都获得了演员工会奖提名吗？是的。嗯，我们在赢得演员工会奖后立即拍摄了这一集。天哪。哦，该死。该死。我应该看看我的日记。我打赌我写下来了。我把它写在日记里了。该死！好的，你写了什么？好的，这是我写的。我们赢得了演员工会奖最佳喜剧群戏奖。我们的桌子就在《24小时》剧组旁边。所以是的，我整晚都在流口水。那是什么？我为什么这么说？
Have you been to the real Poor Richards in Scranton, Angela? Yes. And do you enter from a parking lot? Yes. And was it a good match? Sort of. Oh, I cannot wait to hear more. Save it. Okay, I'll save it. I'll save it. I'll save it. All right, I'm going to move us on to FastFact number three. Lady. What? Do you remember during Ben Franklin when we said that the SAG nominating guy came to set to tell us that we were all nominated for SAG Awards? Yeah. Well, we shot this episode right after we won our SAG Award. Oh my gosh. Oh, dang it. Dang it. I should have looked in my journal. I bet I wrote about it. I wrote about it in my journal. Dang it! Okay, what'd you write? Okay, here's what I wrote. We won the SAG Award for Best Comedic Ensemble Cast. Our table was right next to the people from 24. So yes, I was drooling all night. What is that? Why am I saying that?
女士，我们真是书呆子。多么棒的一群人。我和基弗谈话。或者我应该说，胡言乱语？这就是我写的。那天晚上晚些时候，我遇到了帕特里克·德姆西。天哪。对吧？
Lady, we were such dorks. What a great group of people. I talked to Kiefer. Or should I say, babbled? That's what I wrote. Later that night, I met Patrick Dempsey. Oh, my God. Right?
他头上旋转着神奇的火花。梦幻这个词完全准确。珍娜，我不知道发生了什么。发生了什么。但当我们写日记时，就像一个 13 岁的女孩在用闪光笔写字，你知道吗？百分之百。这是什么日记？我写这个的时候是一个成年女性。我知道。好的，然后我写道，那天晚上最棒的部分可能是奥斯卡、大卫、安吉拉、凯特、她的男朋友和我开始在一个没有舞池的聚会中间跳舞。
He has magic sparkles that rotate around his head. The word dreamy is completely accurate. Jenna, I don't know what happens. happens to the two of us. But when we write in our journals, it's like a 13-year-old girl is writing in sparkly pencil, you know? A hundred percent. What is this diary? I was a grown woman when I wrote this. I know. All right. Then I wrote, the best part of the night was probably when Oscar, David, Angela, Kate, and her boyfriend and I all started dancing in the middle of a party that did not have a dance floor.
那听起来像我们。确实像。但我们掀起了一股热潮，很快一群人都加入了。我想那是那天晚上。我和杰克·麦克布瑞尔跳了一种非常摇滚版的查尔斯顿舞。我向后退，正好踩在奥斯卡约会的脚上。哦，记得那个吗？我感觉太糟糕了。
That sounds like us. That does. But we started a craze and soon a bunch of people were all going to town. I think that's the night. I was doing like a really kind of rock and roll version of the Charleston with Jack McBrayer. And I stepped back right onto Oscars Dates' foot. Oh, remember that? I felt so bad.
现在，这不是你穿着裙子跳进游泳池的那天晚上，是吗？那是后来。不，那是另一天晚上。我们会谈到那个的，伙计们。一直想做。人们穿着漂亮的裙子跳进游泳池。记得安吉丽娜·朱莉有一次这样做吗？看，她没参加这个聚会。
Now, this isn't the night that you jumped into the pool with your dress on, is it? That's later. No, that's a different night. We'll get to that, guys. Always wanted to do it. People had jumped in a pool in their fancy dresses. Remember Angelina Jolie did this one time? Look, she wasn't at this party.
但我下定决心这辈子要做一次。我很后悔没做。哦，我告诉你，回家的车程糟透了。但第一部分很神奇。好的，伙计们，我们要休息一下，我们会回来解析这一集，《鸡尾酒》。是的。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。
But I was determined to do this once in my life. I regret not doing it. Oh, I'll tell you, the car ride home sucked. But the first part was magical. All right, guys, well, we're going to take a break, and we will be back to break down this episode, Cocktails. Yeah. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.
你知道，有时我们会去一些有趣的地方寻求支持。也许是理发师、咖啡师，也许是洗手间里的陌生人寻求生活建议，但并不是每个人都是治疗师。你可以在 BetterHelp 找到你的合适人选。Better Help 治疗师经过临床培训和认证。他们按照严格的行为准则工作，并在美国获得完全许可。BetterHelp 为你完成初步匹配工作，这样你就可以专注于你的治疗目标。
You know, sometimes we turn to some funny places for support. Maybe a hairdresser, a barista, maybe a random stranger in the bathroom for life advice, but not everyone is a therapist. You can find your right match with BetterHelp. Better Help therapists are clinically trained and credentialed. They work according to a strict code of conduct and are fully licensed in the U.S. And BetterHelp does the initial matching work for you, so you can focus on your therapy goals.
你会得到一份简短的问卷，帮助确定你的需求和偏好，然后他们会为你匹配一位持证治疗师。作为世界上最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp 可以提供接触具有多种专业知识的心理健康专业人员的机会。通过 BetterHelp 找到合适的人。我们的听众在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 首次订购可享受 10% 的折扣。那是 BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com/officeladies。
You'll get a short questionnaire that helps identify your needs and preferences, and then they will match you with a licensed therapist. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Find the one with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies.
嘿，大家好。我是 Maddie，我是 Poodle。我们一起主持播客 Reality Gays。我们是两个荒谬的同性恋者，除了谈论真人秀电视节目并对其进行拆解之外，什么都不喜欢。所以无论是《90天未婚夫》、《爱是盲目的》、《锁后之爱》，还是任何其他关于寻找爱情的孤独之心的垃圾电视节目，你的同性恋好友都能满足你，乔。
Hey, y'all. I'm Maddie, and I'm Poodle. And together, we host the podcast Reality Gays. We are two ridiculous homosexuals who love nothing more than talking about reality television and tearing in a new one. So whether it's 90-day fiancé, love is blind, love after lockup, or any other trash TV show about lonely hearts looking for love, your gay besties got you cover, Joe.
每周都有新节目。在任何你获取播客的地方关注并收听 Reality Gays。让我们去爱吧。Tim 的新炒蛋牛角面包。还是叫可颂？无论你怎么说。用刚打碎的炒蛋放在黄油味、片状的可颂面包上开始你的一天。今天就在 Sims 尝试枫糖棕黄油口味，在加拿大的参与餐厅限时供应。
New shows every week. Follow and listen to reality gays wherever you get your podcast. Let's love. Tim's new scrambled egg loaded croissant. Or is it croissant? No matter how you say it. Start your day with freshly cracked scrambled eggs loaded on a buttery, flaky croissant. Try it with maple brown butter today at Sims, at participating restaurants in Canada for limited time.
好的，伙计们，我们回来了。现在，在我为你解析冷开场之前，我有几个观察结果要和你分享，我记得。第一，史蒂夫病了。你记得吗，珍娜？真的吗？是的。我不记得了。他这周得了感冒，你可以听出来。如果你重看，你可以听出来。
All right, you guys, we are back. Now, before I break down the cold open for you, I have a few observations to share with you that I remember. Number one, Steve was sick. Do you remember, Jenna? Really? Yes. I don't. He had like a cold bug this week, and you can hear it. You can hear it if you rewatch.
所以他真的必须坚持下去。因为有几个场景他感觉不舒服。而且没有菲利斯。菲利斯去度蜜月了。哦，是的。是的，所以没有菲利斯。然后，在我们进入冷开场之前，网上这一集的幕后花絮非常棒。
So he really had to power through. because there were a few scenes he was not feeling well in. And no Phyllis. No Phyllis is on her honeymoon. Oh, yes. Yeah. So no Phyllis. And then, before we get into the cold open, the blooper reel that's online for this episode is fantastic.
我女儿很喜欢。我们看了又看。现在我可以看到人们笑场的时刻了。我会随着我们的进行指出它们，好吗？哦，我喜欢它们。好的，那么在这个冷开场中，迈克尔要炫耀他的魔术技巧，你知道他参加了魔术营，他穿了一件紧身衣，德怀特正在用锁链固定他，他要锁上它，然后向大家展示他如何成为胡迪尼并从中逃脱。是的，嗯，我们有一个粉丝问题
My daughter loved it. We watched it over and over. And now I can see these moments where people were breaking. I'm going to point them out as we go, okay? Oh, I love them. that all right so in this cold open michael is going to show off his magic skills you know he's been in magic camp and he has a straight jacket on dwight is securing chains around him he's going to lock it up and then show everyone how he can be a houdini and get out of it yes well we had a fan question
关于这个，安。梅根·基尔、瑞安·科布、艾莉·乔·希金博瑟姆、夏洛特·尼古拉斯和克莱尔·尼科尔斯都问史蒂夫必须穿那件紧身衣多久？他在那东西里待了一上午。是的，我问了肯特·扎博纳克，因为，你知道，他保留了我们制作日期的所有日志。你在开玩笑吗？这就是他告诉我所有这些事情的方式，安吉拉。他有所有的通告单和制作日志，以及所有的，他把一切都存档了。我知道他有很多信息。
about this ang megan keel ryan cobb alley joe higginbotham charlotte nicholas and Claire Nichols all asked how long did Steve have to be in that straight jacket? He spent the morning in that thing. Yeah, I asked Kent Zabornack about it because, you know, he keeps all the logs from our production days. Are you kidding me? That's how he tells me all this stuff, Angela. He has all of the call sheets and the production logs and all the, he has it all on file. I knew he had a lot of information.
我没意识到他有像制作日志那样的东西。显示我们在每个场景上花费的时间增量。这太疯狂了。是的，他说总共史蒂夫穿紧身衣大约一个半小时。我们没有拍那么多条。根据他的记录，我们拍了大约七八条。但现在知道史蒂夫在地上翻滚试图从那件疯狂的衣服里出来时生病了，天哪。是的。
I didn't realize he had like the production logs. that show the time increments we spent on each scene. That is crazy. Yeah, he said that all told Steve was in the straight jacket for about an hour and a half. We didn't do that many takes. We did about seven or eight based on his records. But knowing now that Steve was sick while he was rolling around on the ground trying to get out of that crazy outfit is, oh my gosh. Yeah.
他就像从椅子上摔下来，像潜水一样穿过桌子，撞倒了一株植物。好吧，这是我的问题。你知道，你看到他嘴里有一个非常、非常大的钥匙，对吧？所以显然，是的。那然后掉在地上，吉姆用脚踩住了它。那只是第一步。我的意思是，假设他能拿到钥匙并解开锁链，他怎么能从紧身衣里出来？
He was like flopping off the chair, like diving across the table, knocking a plant over. Well, here's my question. You know, you saw that he had the very, very large key in the corner of his mouth, right? So obviously, yes. That then falls on the ground and Jim steps on it with his foot. That was just step one. I mean, let's say he was able to get the key and undo the chains. how is he going to get out of the straight jacket?
我不知道，但在幕后花絮中，在一条拍摄中，史蒂夫成功地从紧身衣里出来了。不。是的，我们都欢呼。哦，等等，我记得拍摄那个场景。我知道。就像同一个时刻。我记得当，就像在篮球比赛中，当他真的投进那些疯狂的球时，我们都欢呼了，但他们不能用它。是的。
I don't know, but in the blooper reel, in one take, Steve manages to get out of the straight jacket. No. Yes, and we all cheer. Oh, wait, I remember shooting that. I know. It was like the same moment. I remember when, like in basketball, when he actually made one of those crazy Hill Mary shots and we all cheered, but they can't use it. Yeah.
是的。嗯，女士，我们还有一个粉丝发现。我喜欢这个。粉丝发现。来自斯特拉·P 和麦迪逊·J。在冷开场中，吉姆对凯文说，祝你周末愉快。那是星期五，没有人穿休闲星期五的衣服。哦，那是一个非常好的发现。我打赌那让你很高兴。他们接着说，休闲星期五不是应该一直存在，直到托比在第五季第 26 集取消它吗？哇。掌声。好的，那么我们应该继续进入这一集吗？是的，让我们开始吧。迈克尔和德怀特准备出发去参加这个大型聚会
Yeah. Well, lady, we also had a fan catch. And I love this. fan catch. It's from Stella P and Madison J. In the cold open, Jim says to Kevin, have a good weekend. It's Friday and no one is dressed for Casual Friday. Oh, that's a very good catch. I bet that made you happy. They went on to say, isn't Casual Friday supposed to exist until Toby cancels it in Season 5, Episode 26. Wow. Applaus. All right. So should we move on and get into this episode. Yes, let's do it. Michael and Dwight are getting ready to leave for this big party at
大卫·华莱士的家。他让德怀特闻他的口气。他只是钻进去了。就像史蒂夫的头是一个 Pez 糖果机。他爬进去了。我不知道他们是怎么熬过那一关的。我知道。我喜欢德怀特的台词。他说，好，但不算棒。是的。哦，好的。是的。好的。好的。然后迈克尔有一个谈话头，伙计们，他真的为他摆出了这一集的赌注。这是简和他的公开派对，他说。他们终于是一对正式的情侣了。这对意义重大。是的。是的。我有一件事，是一个关于某人即将笑场的幕后花絮发现。伙计们，在 3 分 15 秒，迈克尔试图看看吉姆是否想拼车。他弯下腰。他说，想拼车吗？约翰无法控制自己。约翰笑得太厉害了。史蒂夫知道这一点。史蒂夫在捉弄他。史蒂夫在花絮中有一点说，你想坐我的赛百灵吗？你知道他知道那
David Wallace's house. He makes Dwight smell his breath. He just gets in there. It's like Steve's head is a Pez dispenser. He's crawling inside it. I don't know how they got through that. I know. And I love Dwight's line. He's like, good, not great. Yeah. Oh, okay. Yeah. Okay. Okay. And then Michael has this talking head, you guys, where he really lays out the stakes of this episode for him. It is Jan and his coming out party, he said. They're finally an official couple. This means a lot to him. Yeah. Yeah. And I have one thing, it's a blooper real catch of someone about to break. You guys, at three minutes, 15 seconds, Michael is trying to see if Jim wants to carpool. He leaned down. He's like, want a carpool? John could not get it together. John was laughing so hard. And Steve knew it. And Steve was messing with him. Steve at one point in the bloopers goes, you want to ride in my seabring? And you know he knew that was
会让约翰笑场。约翰被它摧毁了。哦，我喜欢史蒂夫那样做的时候。他大部分时间都对约翰这样做，因为他会发现一些小事。通常是在他靠得非常、非常近的时候。是的。想拼车吗？是的。想坐我的赛百灵吗？是的。
going to make John break. John was like destroyed by it. Oh, I loved it whenever Steve would do that. And he would do it to John mostly because he would find some little thing. And it was usually when he would get like real, real close. Yeah. You want a carpool? Yeah. Want to ride my seep ring? Yeah.
看这个真的很有趣。所以现在我们切到迈克尔和德怀特在车里。德怀特说，非常感谢你带我来。迈克尔说，等一下。我应该带你来吗？我不知道。是的。然后简在免提电话上打来。
It's really fun to watch. So now we cut to Michael and Dwight are in the car. And Dwight is like, thank you so much for bringing me along. And Michael's like, wait a second. Should I have brought you along? I don't know. Yeah. And then Jan calls on speakerphone.
我们在这集里发现迈克尔对她的昵称了吗？他叫她什么？他说，你好，毛茛。哦。这是《公主新娘》的时刻吗？听起来像。一点点。嗯，简说，我们不去这个派对了，我们就像我们在牙买加那个黑沙滩上那样对待彼此怎么样？
And do we find out Michael's nickname for her in this? What does he call her? He says, hello, Buttercup. Oh. Is this a Princess Bride moment? It sounds like it. A little bit. Well, Jan is like, what do you say we blow off this party and we just like, we just go after each other like we did on that black sand beach in Jamaica?
是的，她不是说类似，我们为什么不互相碰撞之类的吗？这是一个真实的视觉形象。我可能不需要。然后她说，等等，我在免提上吗？摄像机在那里吗？她说，我会在派对上见到你。但迈克尔，迈克尔，他不想和简发生关系。他就像，不，我想和你一起去这个派对，向大家展示你和我在一起。
Yeah, doesn't she say something like, why don't we just smash up on each other or something? It's a real visual image. I probably didn't need. And then she's like, wait, am I on speakerphone? Are the cameras there? And she's like, I'll just see you at the party. But Michael, Michael, it does not want to go get it on with Jan. He is like, no, I want to go to this party with you and show everyone that you and I are together.
我知道。这有点让我心碎，因为它对他来说显然很重要。而她只是想把它吹掉。她不想和他公开。他有点强迫她。简，我知道你是一个虚构人物，你永远不会听到这个，但我需要说出来。总是假设你在免提上，摄像机在滚动。这在她身上经常发生。
I know. This kind of breaks my heart because it's clearly so important for him. And she just wants to blow it off. She doesn't want to go public with him. And he's kind of forcing her hand. And Jan, I know you're a fictional character and you won't ever hear this, but I need to say it. always assume you're on speaker phone and cameras are rolling. This is something that comes up with her all the time.
她说，摄像机在那里吗？我说，你为什么要问？放弃吧。它们在那里。这太真实了。嗯，然后珍娜，当他们在路上时，我们在前台，罗伊和帕姆。帕姆说，罗伊，今晚和我们一起出去吧。他说，不，我哥哥在喷气滑雪上赔了钱。
She's like, are the cameras there? I'm like, why are you asking? Just give up. They're there. It's so true. Well, then Jenna, as they're often on their way, we have at front reception, Roy and Pam. And Pam was like, Roy, come out with us tonight. And he's like, no, my brother took a bath on the jet skis.
她说，摄像机在那儿吗？我说，你问这个干嘛？放弃吧，它们就在那儿。真是太对了。好吧，珍娜，因为他们经常在路上，我们在前台有罗伊和帕姆。帕姆说，罗伊，今晚跟我们一起出去吧。他说，不，我兄弟在摩托艇上亏了一大笔钱。
We're going to go get drunk. And you're like, yeah, we're going to a bar. We're going somewhere where that can happen. And you've got to do boyfriend stuff. If you want to be my boyfriend, right? You make a big speech. Yeah. And Roy is like, okay.
我们要去喝醉了。你就像，是的，我们要去酒吧。我们要去一个能发生那种事的地方。你得做男朋友该做的事。如果你想当我的男朋友，对吧？你发表了一大通演说。是的。然后罗伊说，好吧。
Mm-hmm. And it's kind of this nice moment where you see Pam as being more assertive and Roy hears her. Well, there's a deleted scene, Jenna, that would have happened right here that I thought was really sweet. where Roy notices your art has been framed and is hanging on the wall. And he compliments it. He's like, hey, oh, my God, it's your art. It's framed. You know, that's so cool.
嗯哼。这是一个很棒的时刻，你看到帕姆变得更加自信，而罗伊也听进去了。嗯，珍娜，这里本来有一个删减片段，我觉得非常甜蜜。罗伊注意到你的画被装裱起来挂在墙上了。他称赞了它。他说，嘿，天哪，这是你的画。它被装裱了。你知道，这太酷了。
And it's this sweet moment that I think would have just extended that beat of where Roy, he's trying. Yeah. Before we move on from this sweet Pam Roy moment, there is a new plant alert. Another new plant at reception? I wish really and truly there was a way that someone could by the end of the nine years tell us how many plants that Pam had had. There is a new plant. It's in a very cute blue ceramic pot with what looks like to be like little colorful balloons on the pot. Hmm. It's very cute.
这是一个甜蜜的时刻，我觉得它本可以延伸罗伊努力的那种感觉。是的。在我们离开这个甜蜜的帕姆和罗伊的时刻之前，有一个新植物警报。前台又多了一盆新植物？我真希望在九年结束时，有人能告诉我们帕姆到底养过多少盆植物。确实有一盆新植物。它在一个非常可爱的蓝色陶瓷花盆里，花盆上看起来有彩色的小气球。嗯。它非常可爱。
It won't last. It's very cute. My gosh. What is this like secret story we're telling about? Pam's ability to care for house plants. Well, it's not much of a story. You know, a friend of mine gave me an air plant recently. It lives on air.
它活不久的。它非常可爱。天哪。我们到底在讲什么关于帕姆照顾室内植物能力的秘密故事？嗯，这算不上什么故事。你知道，我朋友最近给了我一盆空气凤梨。它靠空气生存。
You like water it once a week. You turn it upside down and you put it in a glass of water and then you put it back in the pot. And you know what, Angela? It's dead. Well, it doesn't sound like a real thing. What? No, it's real. An air plant is real.
你每周给它浇一次水。你把它倒过来放进一杯水里，然后再把它放回花盆里。你知道吗，安吉拉？它死了。嗯，这听起来不像真的。什么？不，它是真的。空气凤梨是真的。
It's a real thing. It was living in air. It's not even in any soil. What do you mean in air? What does that even look like? It looks like a plant. It's in a piece of wood, but there's no soil or water in the pot. Okay. Okay. It's like a ferny kind of plant. Okay. And then you, the idea is that this is the thing that people who can't keep other plants alive can keep alive because it lives on air. I don't know, but mine is dead.
它是真实存在的东西。它生活在空气中。它甚至不需要任何土壤。你说的生活在空气中是什么意思？那看起来是什么样子的？它看起来像一株植物。它在一块木头上，但花盆里没有土壤或水。好吧。好吧。它就像一种蕨类植物。好吧。然后，人们的想法是，那些养不活其他植物的人可以养活它，因为它靠空气生存。我不知道，但我的那盆死了。
Is it like a fancy chia pet? No, no. It's an airplant. It was an airplane. It was. Oh my gosh, you and Pam can't keep plants alive. We can't. Well, listen, Pam is now going to have her big moment in her talking head.
它就像那种花哨的奇亚宠物吗？不，不。它是空气凤梨。它是空气凤梨。确实是。天哪，你和帕姆都养不活植物。我们确实养不活。好吧，听着，帕姆现在要在她的采访中迎来她的高光时刻了。
All right, everyone? She is going to start being direct with people. she's going to start asking for what she wants. She says, look out world, old Pammy is getting what she wants. And don't call me Pammy. Yeah. I get that quoted to me a lot. Do you really?
好了，各位？她要开始直接面对人们了。她要开始争取她想要的东西了。她说，世界，小心了，老帕米要得到她想要的东西了。还有，别叫我帕米。是的。我经常被人引用这句话。真的吗？
Yeah, and don't call me Pammy. The things people quote us are so different. Like I get poop. It's raining from the ceilings. Poop. Well, we had a fan question from Ashley Portugal and Stephanie Shipman Barani. In this episode, when Pam decides she's going to be more assertive, and she says, and don't call me Pammy, it kind of leads us to believe that she doesn't like that nickname.
是的，还有别叫我帕米。人们引用我们的话真是太不一样了。比如我得到的是“大便。天花板在下大便。大便。”嗯，我们有一个来自阿什利·葡萄牙和斯蒂芬妮·希普曼·巴拉尼的粉丝提问。在这一集中，当帕姆决定她要变得更自信时，她说“别叫我帕米”，这让我们觉得她不喜欢那个昵称。
But in the next episode, when Roy and Pam are talking at the diner, he calls her Pammy. Do you think that was a way of showing how Roy doesn't really know or pay much attention to Pam and her likes and dislikes? Yeah. I think this is planting the seed for this nickname of Pam. that she's probably said, I don't love that nickname. And he just is the guy who's like, oh, whatever, tickle, tickle, Pammy. Yeah. And you're like, no, I actually mean it.
但在下一集中，当罗伊和帕姆在餐馆交谈时，他叫她帕米。你认为这是为了表现罗伊并不真正了解或关注帕姆以及她的喜好吗？是的。我认为这为“帕米”这个昵称埋下了伏笔。她可能说过，我不喜欢那个昵称。而他就是那种说“哦，随便啦，挠挠，挠挠，帕米”的人。是的。而你就像，不，我是认真的。
Like, I really don't like being called Pammy. And he's like, okay, Pammy. Yeah. Right? And then you just give up. Yeah. And you're like, okay. Okay, fine.
就像，我真的不喜欢被叫帕米。而他说，好吧，帕米。是的。对吧？然后你就放弃了。是的。然后你就像，好吧。好吧，随你便。
Yeah, I think it is just that thing where Roy just, he just kind of doesn't see her. He tried. but they're just not meant to be together. Now Dwight and Michael have arrived incredibly early to the party. There are catering vans and guys carrying in flowers. Dwight realizes pretty quickly that Michael is dressed like the servants. That's what he calls them. Yeah.
是的，我觉得这就是罗伊根本看不见她的那种情况。他尝试过。但他们注定不适合在一起。现在德怀特和迈克尔非常早地到达了派对。那里有餐饮车和搬运鲜花的人。德怀特很快意识到迈克尔穿得像仆人。那是他称呼他们的方式。是的。
And then they, of course, have to change clothes in the driveway. And once again, we see Dwight's belly. Someone track that. How many plants die and how many times do we see Dwight's belly? Well, I love it that Michael says, only good friends arrive early to a party. So the best way to become a good friend is to come early. Yeah. That's what you do.
然后他们当然得在车道上换衣服。我们又一次看到了德怀特的肚子。有人记录一下吗。有多少植物死了，我们看了多少次德怀特的肚子？嗯，我喜欢迈克尔说的，只有好朋友才会早到派对。所以成为好朋友的最好方法就是早到。是的。这就是你要做的。
That's his strategy. His strategy is to be the first ones there and the last one's to leave. And then you're going to love him. You know, that reminds me of Ellie Kemper. You know, Ellie Kemper had a rule to always be the last person at a party. I know. And she is fun. And you sort of adopted that with her.
这是他的策略。他的策略是第一个到，最后一个走。然后你就会喜欢他。你知道，这让我想起了艾莉·坎珀。你知道，艾莉·坎珀有一个规则，总是派对上最后走的人。我知道。而且她很有趣。你和她在一起时也采用了这一点。
Yeah, because she told me that once. And I was like, oh, I'm always the first one at a party. I like to come in the early part. And here's why. I'm not going to come so early that you're just getting out of the shower. Okay. And your house isn't ready. I like to get there early.
是的，因为她有一次告诉了我。我就说，哦，我总是派对上第一个到的。我喜欢早点去。原因如下。我不会早到到你还在洗澡。好吧。而且你的房子还没准备好。我喜欢早点到。
I get my face time with the host. Mm-hmm. You know, get to have a sort of. meaningful conversation because they're not juggling a lot of people yet. And then I'm there as everyone arrives and I get to chit chat with everyone. I feel overwhelmed when I enter a party and it's like two hours in. I'm like, oh my gosh, it's like too much like instant party for me. I need to ease into a party. I need the population of the party to grow around me slowly. I think this is your metaphor for life though, Jenna. I feel like you need to ease into situations.
我能和主人面对面交流。嗯哼。你知道，能进行某种有意义的对话，因为他们还没忙着应付很多人。然后当每个人到达时我都在那里，我可以和每个人闲聊。当我在派对开始两小时后进入时，我会感到不知所措。我心想，天哪，这对我来说太像即时派对了。我需要慢慢融入派对。我需要派对的人群在我周围慢慢增加。我觉得这是你对生活的隐喻，珍娜。我觉得你需要慢慢适应各种情况。
Yeah, well, I have a lot of social anxiety. So my way of navigating large social situations is to ease in. I don't like an instant crowd. I like the instant crowd. I want to jump in. I want the music thumping. I want everyone to have had like a little bit of a cocktail. The pressure's off on me.
是的，嗯，我有很严重的社交焦虑。所以我应对大型社交场合的方式就是慢慢融入。我不喜欢即时的人群。我喜欢即时的人群。我想跳进去。我想要音乐轰鸣。我想要每个人都喝了一点鸡尾酒。压力从我身上卸下了。
I can just show up and just be part of the flow. You get there early. I don't know, Jenna. You might get stuck in a conversation that goes on forever. Well, that happens. That happens. I'll take it. I'd rather do that than the other thing. And also, if you come early and you chat with the host, if I start to get overwhelmed, if my anxiety gets too high, Irish exit. I can leave. You just fade out. But I was there. Everyone knows I was there, right? And then just the social sort of like obligation is completed. Do I sound like fun? You are fun. You actually are a ton of fun. I am fun. And you're a ton of fun. It's just so fascinating to me. You and I have all of these core things that are so the same. And then all of our social stuff is completely different. It's so true. I always say Angela's House is like an episode of Three's company. There's just people
我可以随便出现，融入其中。你早点到。我不知道，珍娜。你可能会陷入一场没完没了的谈话中。嗯，那确实会发生。那确实会发生。我接受。我宁愿那样也不愿做另一件事。而且，如果你早点到并和主人聊天，如果我开始感到不知所措，如果我的焦虑太高，我就“爱尔兰式退出”。我可以离开。你只是悄悄溜走。但我确实在那里。每个人都知道我在那里，对吧？然后社交义务就完成了。我听起来很有趣吗？你很有趣。你其实非常有趣。我很有趣。你也非常有趣。这对我来说太迷人了。你和我有很多核心的东西是一样的。然后我们所有的社交方式却完全不同。太对了。我总是说安吉拉的家就像《三人行》的一集。总是有各种人
coming through the door randomly at all times. It's true. I'm just like, come on in. I'm out back. Come down the driveway. It's like, your neighbor. You're a neighbor. You. You're a neighbor. You. You're You're contractor. I don't know. Literally anyone coming on over. Creed comes with his guitar. I know. And I'm like, make an appointment. Make an appointment. Show up on time. I need to ready myself for the social interaction. Okay. So now the whole gang is arriving to poor Richards. And I have a little bit of poor Richards trivia, Jenna. Oh, is this about the real poor Richards because we had two people right in Lucas, Bundros and Andrew L. said, is poor Richards a real pub that people can go to today? And if so, where is it? Yes, it is a real pub. And it is in Scranton, Pennsylvania. And here's the thing
随机地从门口进来。是真的。我就是那种，进来吧。我在后面。从车道下来。就像，你的邻居。你是邻居。你。你是邻居。你。你是你的承包商。我不知道。字面上任何人都可以过来。克里德带着他的吉他来了。我知道。而我就会说，预约一下。预约一下。准时出现。我需要为社交互动做好准备。好吧。现在整帮人都到了“可怜的理查德”。我有一点关于“可怜的理查德”的冷知识，珍娜。哦，这是关于真正的“可怜的理查德”吗？因为我们有两个人写信来，卢卡斯·邦德罗斯和安德鲁·L说，“可怜的理查德”是今天人们可以去的真正的酒吧吗？如果是的话，它在哪里？是的，它是一家真正的酒吧。它在宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿。事情是这样的
that was kind of interesting, Jenna, where we shot in Los Angeles was attached to a bowling alley, right? Yep. So is poor Richards. It is not a standalone bar. It is. Part of a bowling alley. Yes. Is the bowling alley called Poor Richards? No. The bowling alley is its own thing. Here's the cool thing.
这很有趣，珍娜，我们在洛杉矶拍摄的地方连接着一个保龄球馆，对吧？是的。所以“可怜的理查德”也是。它不是一个独立的酒吧。它是保龄球馆的一部分。是的。保龄球馆叫“可怜的理查德”吗？不。保龄球馆有它自己的名字。酷的地方在于。
Poor Richards actually does have a door that goes into the bar from the outside. But when you go into the bar, there's a whole section of it that just opens out into the bowling alley. Wow. Yeah. That's exactly what it's like at Pickwick. Yeah. And right next to the door to go inside is like an old-timey-looking wooden plaque thing. that says poor Richards. And I have a photo I took by it. Actually, in 2018, my husband and I were
“可怜的理查德”确实有一扇门可以从外面进入酒吧。但当你进入酒吧时，它有一整块区域直接通向保龄球馆。哇。是的。那和皮克威克的情况一模一样。是的。就在进门的旁边有一个看起来很老式的木牌。上面写着“可怜的理查德”。我有一张我在它旁边拍的照片。事实上，在2018年，我和我丈夫
randomly driving through Pennsylvania. And I was like, oh my God, it's a good hour and a half out of the way. But let's go to Scranton. And we drove to Scranton. And we drove all around. And I said, let's go to poor Richards and grab a beer. But it was closed. Oh, no. I know. So I took all these pictures by the plaque. But years and years ago, 2017, I was there. And I was there. And I I went inside poor Richards with Brian Baumgartner. What was that like? It was such a blast. We just drank beer and hung out with the folks from Scranton who were all so nice.
随机开车穿过宾夕法尼亚州。我就说，哦，天哪，这离我们要去的地方远了一个半小时。但我们去斯克兰顿吧。我们开车去了斯克兰顿。我们到处转了转。我说，我们去“可怜的理查德”喝杯啤酒吧。但它关门了。哦，不。我知道。所以我拍了所有在牌子旁边的照片。但很多年前，2017年，我在那里。我在那里。我和布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳一起进了“可怜的理查德”。那是什么感觉？太棒了。我们只是喝了啤酒，和来自斯克兰顿的人们待在一起，他们都非常友好。
And I just loved that town. Yeah, me too. I've only been there the one time, but it was so great. It's so fun. But yeah, I have some great photos from poor Richards. But yeah, you guys, families are bowling, and then folks are in the bar just right there on the side. But I want to tell you guys, if you go to Poor Richards, here's something that you would never think. They have so many different types of French fries.
我真的很喜欢那个小镇。是的，我也是。我只去过那一次，但真的很棒。太有趣了。但是的，我有一些在“可怜的理查德”拍的很棒的照片。但是的，伙计们，家庭在打保龄球，然后人们就在旁边的酒吧里。但我得告诉你们，如果你去“可怜的理查德”，有一件事你绝对想不到。他们有各种各样的炸薯条。
Tell me more. You can get regular French fries. You can get French fries with gravy. French fries with cheese. French fries with cheese and gravy. Chili cheese fries. Devil fries, which are smothered and hot or mild sauce with your choice of cheese. Pizza fries, which have garlic parmesan seasoned fries with pizza cheese and marinera.
多告诉我一些。你可以点普通的炸薯条。你可以点肉汁炸薯条。奶酪炸薯条。奶酪肉汁炸薯条。辣椒奶酪薯条。恶魔薯条，就是淋上热或温和的酱汁，配上你选择的奶酪。披萨薯条，就是大蒜帕尔马干酪调味的薯条，配上披萨奶酪和马里纳拉酱。
Bacon, cheddar ranch fries, spicy curly fries, or sweet potato fries with salted caramel and marshmallow glaze. Did you order any fries when you were there with Brian? I did. Which ones? I cut the plain ones. I didn't realize they had so many others. They were like, what would you like? I was like, I'll have some french fries, you know, because I was just trying to snack.
培根切达牧场薯条，香辣卷曲薯条，或者配上咸焦糖和棉花糖釉的红薯薯条。你和布莱恩在那里的时候点过薯条吗？点过。哪种？我点了普通的。我没意识到他们有那么多其他的。他们问，你想点什么？我说，我要点些炸薯条，你知道，因为我只是想吃点零食。
Had I known, I think I would have hit up those bacon cheddar ranch fries. Wow. Mm-hmm. I see a road trip in our future. Oh, good Lord. I would love that. You and I driving through Scranton? Oh, come on. We have to make that happen. We've got a list. We've got a list. We've got a bucket list. You guys, you can find out more about poor Richards. You can go to poor Richards pub.com. Well, the gang all sits around the table and they're having some drinks. And Pam, ask Kevin about his wedding plans. Yeah. And he's like, yeah, we set a date. Everyone's so excited to hear more. And then he's like, you know what?
如果我早知道，我想我会点那些培根切达牧场薯条。哇。嗯哼。我预见到了我们的公路旅行。哦，天哪。我很乐意。你和我开车穿过斯克兰顿？哦，来吧。我们必须实现它。我们有一个清单。我们有一个清单。我们有一个遗愿清单。伙计们，你们可以在 poorrichardspub.com 了解更多关于“可怜的理查德”的信息。好吧，大家围坐在桌子旁，喝着酒。帕姆问凯文关于他的婚礼计划。是的。他说，是的，我们定好了日期。每个人都很兴奋想听更多。然后他说，你知道吗？
It's complicated and I'd really like some space. Yeah, I need some space on this. What? At seven minutes, three seconds. There is a fantastic close up of Brian's tiny curled hair on other side of his head. Oh. Yes, the ladies in hair and makeup really must have hit, hit that curling arm. Hard. Wait, Jen, I have to show it to you. You have to see. This is a, what should we call this? Puffy Kevin hair alert. Okay. Wow. That is, I think he needs a haircut. Is what I see when I look at that. Yeah, I think so. I think maybe his hair had gotten long, but it's a big curl on either side of his head. It kind of looks like he has gigantic ears underneath his hair that they're covering up maybe.
这很复杂，我真的需要一些空间。是的，我在这件事上需要一些空间。什么？在7分3秒时。有一个布莱恩头两侧卷曲的小头发的精彩特写。哦。是的，发型和化妆的女士们一定是用卷发棒狠狠地卷了。用力。等等，珍娜，我得给你看。你必须看看。这是一个，我们该叫它什么？凯文蓬松头发警报。好吧。哇。那是，我觉得他需要理发。这就是我看到那个时想到的。是的，我也这么认为。我想也许他的头发变长了，但他头两侧有很大的卷。看起来他头发下面好像有巨大的耳朵，也许他们在遮盖。
It looks like something's hiding in his hair, right above his ear. It does. Well, listen, Ang, Roy now arrives with his brother, Kenny, and they're going to buy a round of drinks for everyone. And I have a lot of questions for you. I also have some thoughts on Roy and Kenny, but I'll save those. Oh, okay. Do you want your questions now, then? Yeah, give me some questions.
看起来他的头发里藏着什么东西，就在耳朵上方。确实。好吧，听着，安吉，罗伊现在带着他的兄弟肯尼到了，他们要请大家喝一轮酒。我有很多问题要问你。我也有一些关于罗伊和肯尼的想法，但我先留着。哦，好吧。那你现在想要你的问题了吗？是的，给我一些问题。
Fan question from Heather Hartline and Molly Pritkin. What was the reason behind Angela going to poor Richards with everyone? She didn't really interact with anyone, and it didn't really seem like she would want to go out to a bar with her co-workers. Was she lashing out because Dwight went to the other party? But before you answer, fan question from Hannah Klinger, Megan Reed, and Devin B. Uh, is Angela crushing on Roy?
来自希瑟·哈特莱恩和莫莉·普里特金的粉丝提问。安吉拉和大家一起去“可怜的理查德”的原因是什么？她并没有真正和任何人互动，而且看起来她也不太想和同事去酒吧。是因为德怀特去了另一个派对，她在发泄吗？但在你回答之前，来自汉娜·克林格、梅根·里德和德文·B的粉丝提问。呃，安吉拉在暗恋罗伊吗？
Angela? Why'd you show up with poor Richards tonight? First of all, at seven minutes, 28 seconds, here is part of that Angela Roy sort of thread that we've seen online. Were they ever a thing? Were they going to be a thing? You can hear off camera, when Roy offers to buy everyone a drink, I say, no, thank you, Roy. Kind of like, eh. Right? Yeah. Here's what I think is the truth, though, guys. We like to think that Angela went there for Roy because it sounds spas. But the deleted scenes tell the real story. Ooh, do tell. Yes.
安吉拉？你今晚为什么出现在“可怜的理查德”？首先，在7分28秒时，这就是我们在网上看到的安吉拉和罗伊那条线索的一部分。他们曾经是一对吗？他们会成为一对吗？你可以听到在镜头外，当罗伊提出要请大家喝酒时，我说，“不，谢谢，罗伊。”有点像，呃。对吧？是的。伙计们，这就是我认为的真相。我们喜欢认为安吉拉是为了罗伊去的，因为这听起来很八卦。但删减片段讲述了真实的故事。哦，快说。是的。
There was a runner between Angela and Oscar at Poor Richards. And I think two things were happening with her character. One, Dwight was busy that night, and she felt like going out with everybody. But also, it seems at least in the deleted scenes that her and Oscar mend the fences even more. Oh. I don't know if you can tell by watching it, but Angela and Oscar actually aren't at the long table where everyone's sitting. They're at a little two-top right next to it. Oh, and they have dinner together. And they have a scene where Oscar has a huge plate of like wings in front of him. He sort of like
在“可怜的理查德”，安吉拉和奥斯卡之间有一段戏。我觉得她的角色发生了两件事。第一，德怀特那天很忙，她觉得和大家一起出去也不错。但同时，至少在删减片段中，她和奥斯卡似乎更加冰释前嫌了。哦。我不知道你看的时候能不能看出来，但安吉拉和奥斯卡其实并没有坐在大家坐的长桌旁。他们坐在旁边的一个小双人桌旁。哦，他们一起吃晚饭。他们有一场戏，奥斯卡面前有一大盘鸡翅。他有点像
takes a bite and makes a gross face and he goes, these wings are all fat and bone. And Angela is eating one carrot and she goes, oh, this place is disgusting. And then the two of them look at each other and smile and Oscar kind of laughs. Oh my gosh. I love it. Yeah. I think Angela is there because her and Oscar were meant to have these scenes together. Hmm. I love that. Yeah. Great question. Great answer. They don't play the game. They're just there kind of hanging out. I know everybody would love a little Roy Angela controversy, but it never happened. guys. Well, let's wait until the next episode because I'm going to have more to say about it then.
咬了一口，做了一个恶心的表情，他说，“这些鸡翅全是肥肉和骨头。”安吉拉正在吃一根胡萝卜，她说，“哦，这个地方真恶心。”然后他们俩看着对方笑了，奥斯卡笑了笑。天哪。我喜欢这个。是的。我觉得安吉拉在那里是因为她和奥斯卡注定要有这些对手戏。嗯。我喜欢这个。是的。好问题。好答案。他们不玩游戏。他们只是在那里闲逛。我知道每个人都想要一点罗伊和安吉拉的争议，但那从未发生过，伙计们。好吧，让我们等到下一集，因为到那时我会有更多的话要说。
Okay. All right, but for now, we had a quick fan catch from Luanda O'Club. When Roy walks into the bar, there is a sign for Fat Tire Beer, which does not distribute to Pennsylvania. Oh, that's a really good catch. A little catch. And then, because we mentioned him, I do want to give a shout out to Roy's brother, Kenny, who is played by Michael Patrick McGill. He does such a good job. Yeah.
好吧。好吧，但现在，我们有一个来自卢安达·奥克拉布的快速粉丝发现。当罗伊走进酒吧时，有一个“胖胎啤酒”的标志，它不在宾夕法尼亚州销售。哦，那是一个非常好的发现。一个小发现。然后，因为我们提到了他，我想向罗伊的兄弟肯尼致敬，他由迈克尔·帕特里克·麦吉尔饰演。他做得太好了。是的。
He came to the art show. He was amazing. He's here in this episode again. Just great. Just great. And I really buy their relationship as brothers. I really believe it. Not only do they look like they could be related to me, but also I just feel like it really fills in the picture of Roy and his family and his dynamic.
他来了艺术展。他太棒了。他这一集又出现了。太棒了。太棒了。我真的很相信他们作为兄弟的关系。我真的相信。不仅他们看起来像是有血缘关系，而且我觉得这真的填补了罗伊和他的家庭以及他的动态的画面。
And why maybe Pam is feeling like she's evolved past that. Well, there's a lot of testosterone in that family. There is. I mean, these are two guys that were going to go out to get hammered because the Jetskees, they didn't get enough money for them or something? Yeah, they didn't sell for what they wanted them to sell for, I guess. But then I feel like Kenny's also just upset that he had to sell them in the first place. Yeah. That's my backstory for Kenny.
以及为什么帕姆可能觉得她已经进化到超越了那个阶段。嗯，那个家庭里有很多睾丸素。确实有。我的意思是，这两个家伙本来要去喝得烂醉，因为喷气滑雪艇，他们没卖到足够的钱还是什么的？是的，我想他们没卖到他们想要的价钱。但我觉得肯尼也只是因为他不得不卖掉它们而感到难过。是的。这就是我为肯尼设定的背景故事。
Yeah. It's both. Mm-hmm. Before we leave poor Richards to go back to David Wallace's house, I absolutely. I absolutely love the story that Toby is now going to spend the whole night trying to get that stupid duck. Yes. Well, the other thing, too, Angela, is I remember how they spent all this time positioning the claw machine right there at the entrance. And they did that on purpose so that Paul wouldn't be in the background of everything.
是的。两者都有。嗯哼。在我们离开“可怜的理查德”回到大卫·华莱士家之前，我绝对。我绝对喜欢托比现在要花整晚时间试图抓那个愚蠢的鸭子的故事。是的。嗯，还有一件事，安吉拉，我记得他们花了多少时间把抓娃娃机放在入口处。他们是故意这样做的，这样保罗就不会出现在所有东西的背景里。
Exactly. He had to be on set with our director, J.J. Abrams. He couldn't be in the background. So it was a very strategic storyline. to get him out of every scene. And a very, very funny fix. Yes. Because, yeah, I guess we should remind everybody
没错。他必须和我们的导演J.J.艾布拉姆斯一起在片场。他不能出现在背景里。所以这是一个非常具有战略意义的故事情节。为了让他离开每一场戏。而且是一个非常非常有趣的修复。是的。因为，是的，我想我们应该提醒大家
that whoever wrote the episode, they shadow the director and they help to produce their episode. And so it's hard to both be on camera and being part of those creative conversations over by the monitors. Yeah. All right.
无论谁写了这一集，他们都会跟随导演，帮助制作他们的剧集。所以既要在镜头前，又要参与监视器旁边的那些创意对话是很困难的。是的。好吧。
Well, let's head back over to David Wallace's house because we forgot to talk about Michael's offering of the potato salad. Yes. We forgot to talk about how he has brought this Tupperware full of potato salad that he has had in his car all day. Well, I love this talking head because he whispers it. And whenever Steve is Michael, like, whispers, like, it just makes me laugh. He's like, it's been out in my car all day. The sun beaten down on it.
好吧，让我们回到大卫·华莱士家，因为我们忘了谈论迈克尔提供的土豆沙拉。是的。我们忘了谈论他带了这整盒特百惠土豆沙拉，而且他在车里放了一整天。嗯，我喜欢这个采访，因为他是在耳语。每当史蒂夫扮演迈克尔时，像这样耳语，就让我发笑。他说，“它在我的车里放了一整天。太阳一直晒着它。”
Man, haze. Yeah. I know. Well, Angela, we had a fan question from Jace Little, who says, in light of Michael bringing potato salad to the party, what are your go-to dishes to bring to parties? Do you have a go-to dish when there's a potluck party? Oh, yeah. I mean, I love to bring a side, because usually if you're going to someone's party, I feel like they sort of do the main stuff and then you bring the side. So there's a few that I love. We do this cornmeal. dip that I really like. My husband, like, my husband has tons of really great dips. Is that shameless plug? Baking with Josh and Ange.com. Tons of really great dips. He does that one. Jenna, you had the dip. We brought over for Super Bowl last year. Do you remember? Yes. It's so good. It's like, it's like a jalapeno chicken dip. It's so good.
伙计，雾气。是的。我知道。嗯，安吉拉，我们有一个来自杰斯·利特尔的粉丝提问，他说，鉴于迈克尔带了土豆沙拉去派对，你带去派对的拿手菜是什么？当有聚餐派对时，你有拿手菜吗？哦，是的。我的意思是，我喜欢带配菜，因为通常如果你去别人的派对，我觉得他们会做主菜，然后你带配菜。所以我有一些我喜欢的。我们做这种玉米面蘸酱，我真的很喜欢。我丈夫，像，我丈夫有很多很棒的蘸酱。这是无耻的广告吗？BakingwithJoshandAnge.com。有很多很棒的蘸酱。他做那个。珍娜，你吃过那个蘸酱。我们去年超级碗带过去的。你记得吗？是的。太好吃了。它就像，它就像墨西哥辣椒鸡肉蘸酱。太好吃了。
Mm-hmm. And then I love these saracha brussel sprouts. I could go on. I don't think I've ever had those. They're so good that he cooks the Brussels sprouts and then he pours over it this marinade he makes with like soy and I think it's got saracha and honey. It's so good. That sounds amazing. It's we're all gone.
嗯哼。然后我喜欢这些是拉差抱子甘蓝。我可以一直说下去。我想我从来没吃过那个。它们太好吃了，他煮了抱子甘蓝，然后淋上他做的腌料，里面有酱油，我想还有是拉差和蜂蜜。太好吃了。听起来太棒了。它我们都吃光了。
That sounds amazing. Okay, we'll bring that next time instead of the chicken jalapeno dip. Well, my son's hockey team would always have these like hockey season kickoff parties or holiday parties. and it would just be a big potluck situation. They would order pizzas, but then, you know, everyone brings something to. And I have two go-toes. What? One, fried chicken from the grocery store.
听起来太棒了。好吧，下次带那个，而不是鸡肉墨西哥辣椒蘸酱。嗯，我儿子的曲棍球队总是会有那种曲棍球赛季开球派对或节日派对。那通常就是大型聚餐的情况。他们会点披萨，但你知道，每个人也会带点东西。我有两个拿手菜。什么？第一，超市买的炸鸡。
Oh, fried chicken you can't go wrong with, especially with little kids. I was talking like adult party. I have a whole different sides for kids stuff. Okay. Well, we always like to bring fried chicken. A friend of mine actually tipped me off to this offering. and it is always a huge hit and I completely stole her idea and we do it all the time. Also, it's really easy because you just pick it up warm from the grocery store on your way to the event.
哦，炸鸡你绝对不会出错，尤其是对小孩子来说。我刚才说的是成人派对。我有完全不同的儿童派对配菜。好吧。嗯，我们总是喜欢带炸鸡。我的一位朋友实际上向我透露了这个提议。它总是大受欢迎，我完全偷了她的主意，我们一直都在做。而且，这真的很简单，因为你在去活动的路上从超市买热的就行了。
Yes. And no one cares that you didn't make it yourself because they're just happy eating it. Yep. But then my other thing that I would do for these potlucks is I do these shredded chicken mini sliders. Yes, I've had those. Yeah, I love them. I actually put them in a cookbook, Angela. I'm in a cookbook.
是的。而且没人会在意你不是自己做的，因为他们吃得很开心。是的。但我的另一件事，我会为这些聚餐做的是，我做这些手撕鸡肉迷你汉堡。是的，我吃过那些。是的，我喜欢它们。我其实把它们放进了一本食谱里，安吉拉。我进了一本食谱。
I know. I'm in. I collaborated on this cookbook with Kings Hawaiian, and I put this recipe in the cookbook. And what you do is you put chicken breasts and you marinate them on low in a crock pot in root beer. That is the secret ingredient. And you do that for several hours until they're all soft. Then you drain the root beer, you shred up the chicken, you put a bunch of barbecue sauce in,
我知道。我进去了。我和夏威夷王合作了这本食谱，我把这个食谱放进去了。你要做的是，你放鸡胸肉，然后用慢炖锅在根汁汽水中腌制。那是秘密配料。你这样做几个小时，直到它们变软。然后你把根汁汽水倒掉，把鸡肉撕碎，放一大堆烧烤酱，
let that cook on low for a couple hours. and then you just bring the whole crock pot along with little slider buns and other accoutremaul. Yeah. And you're like, here you go. It's sort of like a spin on like a pulled pork sandwich, but it's chicken. Yeah. Those are my go-toes. I think those are great.
让它在低火下煮几个小时。然后你只要带上整个慢炖锅，配上小汉堡面包和其他配料。是的。然后你就像，给你。这有点像手撕猪肉三明治的变体，但它是鸡肉。是的，这些是我的拿手菜。我觉得它们很棒。
Well. Jace Little asked. All right. Well, should we move on? Because now Dwight is at the buffet. I love a buffet. And he tells the woman, that is fine, lady. You love a buffet.
好吧。杰斯·利特尔问的。好吧。好吧，我们继续吧？因为现在德怀特在自助餐台。我喜欢自助餐。他告诉那个女人，“那样很好，女士。”你喜欢自助餐。
If I say buffet, I should just pause and let you have your moment. I'm always going to have a moment. Well, Dwight tells her that the piece of shrimp she's eating, that the line on the back of the shrimp is poop. Yeah. And you know what? What? It is poop. I looked it up.
如果我说自助餐，我应该停下来让你享受你的时刻。我总是会有时刻的。嗯，德怀特告诉她，她正在吃的虾，虾背上的那条线是大便。是的。你知道吗？什么？那是大便。我查过了。
Oh, yeah, it is. So here's what I found out. Yeah. If you're going to cook the shrimp, then you don't have to devane it. They call it devaning, but it's not a very valid. It's poop. I think they call it devaning because no one wants to really think about the fact that we're just scraping poop off their backside. Yeah.
哦，是的，它是。所以我发现的是。是的。如果你要煮虾，那你就不必去虾线。他们叫它去虾线，但它不是一个非常有效的。那是大便。我想他们叫它去虾线是因为没人想真正去想我们只是在刮掉它们背面的大便。是的。
So anyway, you should depop it if you're not going to cook it. Like a shrimp cocktail? Right. But if you're going to cook it, you can just leave the poop there because the cooking will kill the bacteria, at least according to this LA Times article that I read about it. Okay. The end. Do you like shrimp? I mean, wow, this is not that important of a question, but I'm really weighing my answer.
所以无论如何，如果你不打算煮它，你应该去大便。就像虾鸡尾酒？对。但如果你要煮它，你可以把大便留在那里，因为烹饪会杀死细菌，至少根据我读到的那篇关于它的《洛杉矶时报》文章是这样。好吧。结束。你喜欢虾吗？我的意思是，哇，这不是一个很重要的问题，但我真的在权衡我的答案。
I know. I don't hate it, but I don't look for it. Right. I think the most shrimp I eat is maybe in a pad tie. What about you? I love shrimp. I love shrimp. You cannot have relatives in Louisiana.
我知道。我不讨厌它，但我不会特意去找它吃。对。我想我吃得最多的虾可能是在泰式炒河粉里。你呢？我喜欢虾。我喜欢虾。你不能有路易斯安那州的亲戚
Indiana and not like shrimp. We talked a lot about food. It's called cocktails, but we're still talking about food. Yeah, I'm hungry. I am too. I don't even know where we're at anymore. I don't either, but I'm going to share something. It's personal.
印第安纳州而不喜欢虾。我们谈了很多关于食物的话题。这叫鸡尾酒，但我们还在谈论食物。是的，我饿了。我也是。我甚至不知道我们现在在哪了。我也不知道，但我会分享一些东西。这是私人的。
Lady, the other night, I ate an entire box of cheddar bunny snack mix. That's over 1,200 calories of cheddar bunnies. Is that like the cheddar bunnies we get for the kids? kids? Yep. Oh, lady. Yeah. Lady. Were you? I had a moment. Did you have a bad day? Yeah, it was just, you know, where it just feels like you're in a hole and you can't get out. And for whatever reason, my tunnel out of the hole was this box of cheddar crackers. Before I knew it, my fingertips were scraping the bottom of the box. I couldn't believe I'd eaten the whole thing. What were you watching? Were you watching something? Yeah, I was watching the show called Search Party.
女士，那天晚上，我吃了一整盒切达兔零食混合物。那超过1200卡路里的切达兔子。那是我们给孩子们买的那种切达兔子吗？是的。哦，女士。是的。女士。你当时？我有一个时刻。你那天过得很糟糕吗？是的，只是，你知道，那种感觉就像你掉进了一个洞里，出不来。不管什么原因，我走出洞的隧道就是这盒切达饼干。在我意识到之前，我的指尖已经在刮盒子底部了。我不敢相信我把整盒都吃了。你在看什么？你在看什么东西吗？是的，我在看一个叫《搜寻派对》的节目。
Oh, yeah. Yeah, it's really good. Yeah. And I was riveted. And before I knew it, I'd finished all of them. And I'm going to say I felt better the next day. I don't know what the moral of this story is, but... How were your BMs?
哦，是的。是的，它真的很好。是的。我被迷住了。在我意识到之前，我已经把它们全吃完了。我要说的是，第二天我感觉好多了。我不知道这个故事的寓意是什么，但是……你的排便怎么样？
Were you okay? Yeah, I was expecting to have a lot more tummy trouble than I did. I was fine. I was fine. Do you ever want to eat one again? I'm craving it. I want another box. And I'm not going to buy it because if it's not in the house, I won't eat it.
你还好吗？是的，我以为我会比实际情况有更多的肚子问题。我很好。我很好。你还想再吃一次吗？我很渴望。我想要另一盒。但我不会买，因为如果家里没有，我就不会吃。
But I had this problem with the Trader Joe's cheese crackers a few years ago, where if I ate one, I ate the whole box. And I managed to get over that. and clearly my new trigger is the cheddar bunny snack mix. It's got everything in it. It's got not just the cheddar bunnies that we love, but it's got like little pretzels and like little cheese at things. Yeah. I was so expecting the story to go differently.
但我几年前在 Trader Joe's 的奶酪饼干上有过这个问题，如果我吃了一个，我就把整盒都吃了。我设法克服了那个。显然我新的触发点是切达兔零食混合物。它里面什么都有。它不仅有我们喜欢的切达兔子，还有像小椒盐卷饼和像小奶酪之类的东西。是的。我太期待这个故事会有不同的走向了。
I thought you were going to tell it to me and say, I came out on the other side. I am done with junk food. I am only going to eat healthy snacks. but you're like, I ate it all. I felt fine. I'd do it again. So you were expecting like the story to go somewhere is what you're saying. You didn't expect it that it would just hit a wall. Actually, Angela, I have been turning things around and we've been texting about it. I'm trying to do physical exercise three to four days a week and I've been eating really good, but I had the
我以为你要告诉我，说，“我从另一边走出来了。我再也不吃垃圾食品了。我只会吃健康的零食。”但你却说，“我全吃了。我感觉很好。我还会再做一次。”所以你的意思是，你期待这个故事会有所发展。你没想到它会直接撞墙。其实，安吉拉，我一直在扭转局面，我们一直在发短信讨论这件事。我正在尝试每周进行三到四天的体育锻炼，而且我一直吃得很好，但我有那个
slow moment with the box of cheddar crackers. I don't know. Sometimes you need to be, okay not being okay right lady who are you talking to i got nothing but love for you with all of that i mean do you remember that night where it was like 11 o'clock at night and i was like well i guess someone needs a piece of chocolate pie i guess that person's me everyone's gone to bed i'm not even going to put it on a plate i'm going to stand inside the fridge and just have a fork and just carve at it you sent me a video message of yourself eating the pie from the fridge. Uh-huh. Yeah. And I'll tell you what, it made me feel better. There you go. There you go. Okay, wait, where are we? Where we are is that Jan and Michael have arrived to the party and they're outside and Jan wants Michael to sign some papers waving his right to sue Dunder Mifflin in the event that their relationship in his mind or in reality interfere.
吃切达饼干盒的缓慢时刻。我不知道。有时候你需要，没关系，没关系，女士，你在和谁说话？我对你只有爱。我的意思是，你还记得那天晚上11点吗？我说，“好吧，我想有人需要一块巧克力派。我想那个人是我。”大家都睡了，我甚至不会把它放在盘子里，我会站在冰箱里，拿个叉子直接挖着吃。你给我发了一个你自己从冰箱里吃派的视频信息。嗯哼。是的。我告诉你，这让我感觉好多了。给你。给你。好吧，等等，我们在哪？我们在大卫·华莱士家，迈克尔和简到了，他们在外面，简想让迈克尔签一些文件，放弃他在他们的关系在他看来或现实中干扰工作时起诉邓德·米夫林的权利。
fears with work. I have to tell you, I laughed so hard when she was digging in her trunk and he said, what you're looking for? You bring a dip? Like, somewhere in Michael's mind, you go to a party, you bring a dip. No matter what party, you bring a dip. He's like, everybody must have brought a dip, right? Also, I cannot get enough of Jan and Michael. I love this relationship. I love Malora hardens so much. She's so phenomenal. God, she's good. Well, you know she has this amazing talking head where she's like, hey, yeah, this is a calculated risk, you know, upside. I'm going to fall deeply in love and have babies and normalcy, no more self-loathing. Downside, she collapses in on herself like a dying star, right? So in the deleted scenes, she has a much longer talking head.
干扰工作。我必须告诉你，当她在后备箱里翻找时，我笑得太厉害了，他说，“你在找什么？你带了蘸酱吗？”就像，在迈克尔的脑海里，你去参加派对，你带蘸酱。无论什么派对，你都带蘸酱。他就像，“每个人一定都带了蘸酱，对吧？”另外，我怎么也看不够简和迈克尔。我喜欢这段关系。我非常喜欢马洛拉·哈登。她太出色了。天哪，她太棒了。嗯，你知道她有一个很棒的采访，她说，“嘿，是的，这是一个经过计算的风险，你知道，上行空间。我会坠入爱河，生孩子，过正常生活，不再自我厌恶。”下行空间，她像一颗垂死的恒星一样向内坍塌，对吧？所以在删减片段中，她有一个长得多的采访。
They really trim this down. And lady, She overshares so much. Like, it's so uncomfortable to watch. What does she say? I mean, she talks about past relationships. She was like, well, I guess one good thing is I orgasm really easily. So, oh, my gosh. She really overshares.
他们真的把它剪短了。女士，她分享得太多了。就像，看的时候太不舒服了。她说了什么？我的意思是，她谈到了过去的关系。她说，“嗯，我想一件好事是我很容易达到高潮。”所以，哦，天哪。她真的分享得太多了。
And I was like, oh, my God. I see why they deleted it. But it really, really does show you where Jan is at, her mental space. Well, as soon as he walks in the door with Jan, they run in to David Wallace, they've barely introduced themselves, and he says Jan and I are lovers. He doesn't say Jan and I are dating. First of all, he doesn't need to say that. He doesn't need to clarify their relationship, but he's so excited. And he always refers to them as lovers. And you guys, I don't. know if you guys have ever had people like this in your life, but I know a couple who when they talk about each other, they refer to each other as their lover. And it makes me so uncomfortable every time. Every time. I remember when they got engaged, we were like, oh, tell us your
我当时想，哦，天哪。我明白为什么他们删掉了它。但这真的，真的展示了简处于什么位置，她的心理空间。好吧，他一进门带着简，他们就遇到了大卫·华莱士，他们还没怎么介绍自己，他就说“简和我是恋人。”他没说“简和我在约会。”首先，他不需要说那个。他不需要澄清他们的关系，但他太兴奋了。他总是称他们为恋人。伙计们，我不知道你们生活中是否遇到过这样的人，但我认识一对夫妇，当他们谈论对方时，他们称对方为他们的恋人。这让我每次都感到非常不舒服。每次。我记得当他们订婚时，我们就像，“哦，告诉我们你们的
engagement story. And they were like, well, we said to each other, you know what? You are my lover. You are my friend. It's always, they always bring it up. up. Is it me and Lee? No. Why are you saying you don't like it that I say that? The Lee and I, the Lee and I refer to one another as lovers. I can't. I want to do it now. The next time I go to a party, I'm going to introduce Lee and I as lover. You know what? This is my lover Lee. Show up really early when there's no one else to buffer your awkward conversation and no one's had a drink yet
订婚故事。”他们就像，“嗯，我们对彼此说，你知道吗？你是我的恋人。你是我的朋友。”总是，他们总是提起它。是李和我吗？不。你为什么说你不喜欢我那样说？李和我，李和我称彼此为恋人。我不能。我现在想这么做了。下次我去派对时，我要把李和我介绍为恋人。你知道吗？这是我的恋人李。在没有其他人来缓冲你尴尬的谈话，而且还没人喝过酒的时候早点出现
and be like, my lover and I are early. And my lover and I brought. Cheez-its or whatever. We brought some bunny snack mix. My lover told me not to eat so many in the car, and I said, lover, you're silly. I can't wait to do this bit at my next party. Oh, it makes me so uncomfortable. So now the party is going at David Wallace's house, and we just have what is possibly one of the most awkward conversations at a party.
然后说，“我的恋人和我来早了。”“我的恋人和我带了。”Cheez-its 或者什么的。我们带了一些兔子零食混合物。“我的恋人告诉我不要在车里吃那么多，我说，恋人，你真傻。”我迫不及待想在下次派对上做这个梗了。哦，这让我感到非常不舒服。所以现在派对在大卫·华莱士家进行，我们刚刚进行了可能是派对上最尴尬的对话之一。
Yeah, nine minutes, 52 seconds. Michael tries to hold Jan's hand. He's already, you know, as we said, called her his lover. Then he tries to hold her hand. She won't hold his hand. Then he blows in her face. Then he asks for an appetizer. Wants to know if they have any bagel bites.
是的，9分52秒。迈克尔试图握住简的手。他已经，正如我们所说，称她为他的恋人。然后他试图握住她的手。她不让他握。然后他对着她的脸吹气。然后他要开胃菜。想知道他们有没有贝果小吃。
Yeah. Then Dwight asked for the square footage of the house. Then Michael's like, that's inappropriate. How much does this house cost? And then doesn't Jim, like, do like a spit take with his drink? Let me tell you something. I was having a cup of tea while I was watching this episode, and I happened to be taking a sip right at this moment. And Jim and I simultaneously spit into our cups from that line.
是的。然后德怀特问房子的平方英尺。然后迈克尔就像，“那是不合适的。”这房子多少钱？然后吉姆不是，像，喝饮料时喷出来了吗？我告诉你一件事。我在看这一集时正在喝茶，我刚好在那一刻喝了一口。吉姆和我同时从那句台词中喷到了杯子里。
That line made me laugh out loud. I know. It's so awkward. And it sends Dwight now on this crazy journey of checking out every nook and cranny of their house. Yes. And this is also where Karen is going to start her little prank on. Jim. She says to Jim, do you see that guy over there? Because I just think you should know, we used to date and it didn't end well. And Jim is like, oh. I didn't like this prank. I didn't like this storyline. Tell me more. Well, I mean, I think it's passive aggressive. I think Karen is maybe still a little stung by the fact that Jim dated Pam and the she found out about it.
那句台词让我大笑出声。我知道。太尴尬了。它让德怀特现在踏上了检查他们房子每一个角落的疯狂旅程。是的。这也是凯伦要开始她对吉姆的小恶作剧的地方。她对吉姆说，“你看到那边那个人了吗？因为我觉得你应该知道，我们曾经约会过，结局不太好。”吉姆就像，“哦。”我不喜欢这个恶作剧。我不喜欢这个故事情节。多告诉我一些。嗯，我的意思是，我觉得这是被动攻击。我觉得凯伦可能还是因为吉姆和帕姆约会过，而且她发现了这件事而感到有点刺痛。
And I feel like this is her kind of playful way to make light of it, although it's not something that she feels light about because they've had all these late night talks. But it's her sort of playful way of, I don't know, kind of jabbing him about it. Yeah. And it feels a little sad and a little desperate to me, Karen. Oh, wow. You said it. it. Well, should we talk about this scene with the scotch? Oh, God. It is so good. There's wonderful
我觉得这是她那种俏皮的方式来淡化它，尽管这不是她觉得轻松的事情，因为他们有过所有这些深夜谈话。但这是她那种俏皮的方式，我不知道，有点刺痛他。是的。这对我来说有点悲伤，有点绝望，凯伦。哦，哇。你说出来了。好吧，我们谈谈这场喝苏格兰威士忌的戏吗？哦，天哪。太棒了。有精彩的
moments in the deleted scenes, too. Oh, my God. Well, I have to say, when Steve takes a sip of this scotch, which David tells us was gifted to him by Lee Ayacocca, Steve starts coughing. And it is some of the best liquor coughing I've ever seen in a performance. It was so real. And it's so amazing, too, because there's a great moment in the bloopers where he's like, over the gums and through the lips. He is not understanding the magnitude of a 20-year-old scotch given by this amazing man who he thinks discovered the Delorean. Yes. All of it is wrong. All of it is wrong. We had a few people write in about that joke and they were like, I don't understand the joke about Lee Ayacocca and the Delorean. And this is just a matter of Michael. He's just mixing up
删除的场景中也有很多精彩瞬间。天哪。嗯，我不得不说，当史蒂夫喝下这口苏格兰威士忌时——大卫告诉我们这是李·艾柯卡送给他的——史蒂夫开始咳嗽。那是我在表演中见过的最真实的酒后咳嗽。太真实了。而且非常神奇的是，花絮里有一个很棒的片段，他说“越过牙龈，穿过嘴唇”。他根本没意识到这瓶由那位了不起的人赠送的20年陈酿苏格兰威士忌有多珍贵，他还以为是那个人发明了德罗宁跑车。是的。全错了。全错了。我们收到了一些观众关于那个笑话的来信，他们说，我不明白关于李·艾柯卡和德罗宁跑车的笑话。这纯粹是迈克尔的问题。他只是搞混了
his automobile executives. Yes, this is classic Michael where he gets one part right and then the rest wrong. Yes. So for anyone who doesn't know, Lee Ayacocca was best known for developing the Ford Mustang and the Pinto cars. He worked for Ford, but then he went on to work at Chrysler, and he was just this huge automobile executive legend, but here is a fun fact. Wow. Lee Ayacocca wrote his autobiography with another writer, William Novak. Holy crap.
他的汽车高管。是的，这就是典型的迈克尔，他能对一部分，剩下的全错。是的。所以对于那些不知道的人，李·艾柯卡最出名的是开发了福特野马和平托汽车。他在福特工作，后来去了克莱斯勒，他简直是汽车高管界的传奇人物，但这里有个有趣的事实。哇。李·艾柯卡是和另一位作家威廉·诺瓦克一起写的自传。天哪。
Yeah. Wait. Wait. Yep. Wait, B.J. Novak's dad. Yep. Was the ghost writer for Leahyakoka's autobiography? Yeah.
是啊。等等。等等。没错。等等，是B.J.诺瓦克的父亲。没错。是李·艾柯卡自传的代笔者？是的。
Am I getting this right? You are. B.J. Novak's father, William Novak, was a ghost writer, but he was also a writer. Yeah. And he wrote this book with Lea Iacocca. I don't want to tell BJ's stories for BJ, but I just want to tell BJ stories for BJ, but I just want everyone to know that his childhood was fascinating. And he had just legendary people who worked with his father, who then BJ had like moments with as a child. As a child. But here's the thing.
我没理解错吧？你没理解错。B.J.诺瓦克的父亲威廉·诺瓦克不仅是代笔者，他本身也是一位作家。是的。他确实和李·艾柯卡合写了那本书。我不想替B.J.讲他的故事，但我只是想让大家知道他的童年非常迷人。他父亲合作过的都是传奇人物，而B.J.小时候和这些人有过接触。小时候。但重点是。
What's so cool about BJ's stories is that he's a kid meeting legends of different industries. And it just makes me think about the time that my husband Lee was making a movie with Billy Joe Armstrong. from Green Day, and Billy Joe would come over to our house and rehearse with Lee for this movie. And my son, who was a big Green Day fan and who is a drummer himself, like hang out with Billy Joe Armstrong. And Billy Joe would, like, show him riffs on the drums and stuff like that. But to my son, he was just like this cool guy named Billy who was coming over. But one day, like when he's older, I'm going to be. like, do you know who was in our house teaching you that whole thing on the high hat? Like,
B.J.的故事最酷的地方在于，他还是个孩子时就见到了各行各业的传奇人物。这让我想起我丈夫李和绿日乐队的比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗一起拍电影的时候，比利·乔会来我们家和李排练。我儿子是绿日乐队的超级粉丝，他自己也是个鼓手，他会和比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗一起玩。比利·乔会教他打鼓的节奏之类的。但在我儿子眼里，他只是个叫比利的酷大叔。但有一天，等他长大了，我会告诉他：“你知道吗？那个在你家教你打镲片的人是谁？”
did that was, do you know who like tuned your bass drum for you that one time? That was Billy Johnstone. Yeah, it's going to be so cool. Jenna, I am there, but I'm there with the office. Because my kids now love the office. They love it. And they want to watch every episode with me. They'll say, you know, what, what episode are you guys doing for office ladies this week? Can we watch with you and half the time they've seen the episode and it's their second or third viewing of it and isabel there's a photo in our kitchen jena you know how i have that i have like a big um bulletin board with a bunch of photos on it and i have a photo of you and i and isabel on a swing set and i'm holding her and it's from company picnic yeah she'd come to set that day at lunch right yeah so the other morning
“你知道那个帮你调低音鼓的人是谁吗？那是比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗。”是的，那会很酷。珍娜，我懂，因为我的孩子们现在也爱看《办公室》。他们超爱。他们想和我一起看每一集。他们会问：“你们这周《办公室女士》要讲哪一集？我们可以一起看吗？”有一半时间他们已经看过那一集了，这是他们第二或第三次看。伊莎贝尔，我们厨房里有一张照片，珍娜，你知道我有个大公告板，上面贴了很多照片，有一张是你、我和伊莎贝尔在秋千上的照片，我抱着她，那是公司野餐那天拍的。对，她那天来片场吃午饭了，对吧？是的，所以前天早上
Isabel was like, Mom, that's company picnic. I was on set for company picnic. I was like, baby, you were on set every week. I just don't have a picture every time. And she was like, oh my gosh. But it's that moment. It's all becoming really real for her. Yeah.
伊莎贝尔说：“妈妈，那是公司野餐。我在公司野餐的片场。”我说：“宝贝，你每周都在片场。我只是没法每次都拍照。”她说：“天哪。”但就是那一刻。这一切对她来说都变得非常真实了。是的。
Well, that was BJ's life. He had, you know, all these crazy people. But he was just like, oh, you know, my dad's friend Lee came over to write a book about cars. Lee Ayacocca. Just Lee Ayacocca. Crazy. Not a biggie. Nice guy.
嗯，那就是B.J.的生活。他认识那些疯狂的人。但他只是觉得，“哦，我爸的朋友李过来写一本关于汽车的书。”李·艾柯卡。只是李·艾柯卡。太疯狂了。没什么大不了的。好人。
Nice fella. Well, lady, we did have a great callback to a character in this scene while they're in the house. We see Dan Gore, who is the regional manager for the Buffalo branch. Yep. Dwight calls him an idiot for not knowing Battlestar Galactica. So I thought that was a nice little callback to season two. And up next, we are going to get into a pretty rowdy drinking game. over at poor Richards.
好家伙。好吧，女士，我们在这一幕中确实有一个对角色的精彩呼应。我们看到了布法罗分公司的区域经理丹·戈尔。没错。德怀特因为他不知道《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》而骂他是白痴。所以我认为这是对第二季的一个很好的小呼应。接下来，我们要进入一场相当吵闹的饮酒游戏，就在理查兹酒吧。
Before we do that, we're going to take a little break. All right. How does that sound? Sounds real good. All right. Okay. Summer's here, and you can now get almost anything you need for your sunny days, delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost?
在那之前，我们要休息一下。好吗？听起来不错。好的。夏天到了，你现在可以通过Uber Eats订购阳光假日所需的一切。我们说的“几乎”是什么意思？
Well, you can't get a well-groom lawn delivered, but you can get a chicken parmesan delivered. A cabana? That's a no. But a banana, that's a yes. A nice tan. Sorry. Nope. But a box fan.
嗯，你不能订购修剪好的草坪，但你可以订购鸡肉帕尔马干酪。凉亭？不行。但香蕉，可以。晒黑？抱歉。不行。但箱式风扇。
Happily, yes. A day of sunshine? No. A box of fine wines? Yes. Uber Eats can definitely get you that. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now. Alcohol and select markets. Product availability may vary by Regency app for details. Hit pause on whatever you're listening to and hit play on your next adventure. This fall get double points on every qualified stay. Life's the trip. Make the most of it at Best Western. Visit bestwestern.com for complete terms and conditions. Bank more oncores when you switch to a Scotiabank banking package. Learn more at scotiabank.com slash banking packages.
可以。一天的阳光？不行。一箱好酒？可以。Uber Eats绝对能帮你搞定。用Uber Eats订购几乎任何东西。立即下单。酒精饮料仅限特定市场。产品供应情况可能因地区而异，详情请查看应用程序。暂停你正在听的内容，开启你的下一次冒险。今年秋天，每次合格住宿可获得双倍积分。生活就是一场旅行。在最佳西方酒店尽情享受吧。访问bestwestern.com了解完整条款和条件。切换到丰业银行银行套餐，获得更多优惠。在scotiabank.com/bankingpackages了解更多信息。
Conditions apply. Scotia Bank, you're richer than you think. All right, guys, we are back, and we are about to start a drinking game called, let me just say, we had a number of fan questions about what it's called. Tracy Williams, Alex Taylor, Nicole Sabino, Bethany DeVish, and Samantha Skelly all said, number one, is the drinking game everyone plays at Poor Richards a real game? Number two, is it called up chickens or up Jenkins? And number three, where did the writers get the idea from?
适用条件。丰业银行，你比你想象的更富有。好了，伙计们，我们回来了，我们要开始玩一个饮酒游戏，让我先说，我们收到了很多粉丝关于这个游戏名字的提问。特蕾西·威廉姆斯、亚历克斯·泰勒、妮可·萨比诺、贝瑟尼·德维什和萨曼莎·斯凯利都问：第一，大家在理查兹酒吧玩的是真实的游戏吗？第二，它叫“Up Chickens”还是“Up Jenkins”？第三，编剧是从哪里得到的灵感？
First of all, yes, this is a real game. It is called Up Jenkins, Down Jenkins. And I will tell you how Paul found out. about it. So Paul's brother Warren went to Kenyon College in Gambier, Ohio, and I was in New York with him, and we were hanging out with his friends from college, Martin and Nellie. This is a game they played in college. We played it all night at a little dive bar in Manhattan. Paul knew about this game from Warren, and he incorporated it into the script. Okay, so how exactly do you play? Okay. Now, according to Warren Martin and Nellie from Kenyon College,
首先，是的，这是一个真实的游戏。它叫“Up Jenkins, Down Jenkins”。我会告诉你们保罗是怎么发现它的。保罗的哥哥沃伦在俄亥俄州甘比尔的凯尼恩学院读书，我和他一起在纽约，我们和他在大学的朋友马丁和内莉在一起玩。这是他们在大学玩的游戏。我们在曼哈顿的一家小酒吧玩了一整晚。保罗从沃伦那里知道了这个游戏，并把它写进了剧本里。好了，那到底怎么玩呢？好的。根据凯尼恩学院的沃伦、马丁和内莉的说法，
this is how you play it. There are two teams on opposing sides of a table. You grab a quarter and you pass it underneath as slyly as possible, right? You're passing the quarter under the table to your teammates. And at any time, the opposing team on the other side of the table can say, one, two, three, up Jenkins. And at that point, every single person has to put their elbows on the table and clench their hands into fists to hide whoever has the quarter, right? Okay. And then the opposing team says, one, two, three, down Jenkins. And at that point, you slam your hands down to the table, everyone at the same time.
玩法是这样的。桌子两边各有一队人。你拿一枚硬币，尽可能隐蔽地在桌子底下传，对吧？你把硬币传给队友。任何时候，桌子对面的对方球队都可以说：“一、二、三，Up Jenkins。”这时，每个人都必须把手肘放在桌子上，握紧拳头，藏住拿硬币的人，对吧？好的。然后对方球队说：“一、二、三，Down Jenkins。”这时，大家同时把手拍在桌子上。
You try to do it at the same time to mask the sound of that quarter hitting the table. Then the opposing team goes down the line and touches every single hand they think doesn't have it, leaving the hand that does have it. Now, okay. Do we know why it's called up Jenkins down Jenkins? Did someone named Jenkins invent it? We don't know why, and when I looked it up on the internet, a few things came up. First of all, Jenkins is a very Welsh name, and apparently there is a version of this in Wales,
你们要尽量同时拍，以掩盖硬币撞击桌子的声音。然后对方球队顺着队伍摸每一只他们认为没有硬币的手，最后剩下那只拿着硬币的手。好了。我们知道为什么叫“Up Jenkins, Down Jenkins”吗？是叫詹金斯的人发明的吗？我们不知道原因，当我在网上查的时候，出现了几种说法。首先，詹金斯是一个非常威尔士的名字，显然威尔士有一个版本，
and it's called Tippett. Oh, I don't know. It is also played in Iraq, and it's called M. Hibs, if I'm saying that correctly. Apparently, it's been documented that a version of this game was played by the Native Americans, and it was called Hand Game. And it's played throughout America. There's several different names. It has been referred to as up chickens in Midwestern states, or sometimes it's just called Jenkins. Well, there you have it, folks. I'm sure there's more information. out there about up Jenkins down Jenkins and if you guys have any let us know jennah do you remember on set me teaching everyone how to play yes i do i do you gave a little tutorial and i was so bummed that
叫“Tippett”。哦，我不知道。它在伊拉克也有人玩，叫“M. Hibs”，如果我发音正确的话。显然，有记录显示美洲原住民玩过这个游戏的版本，叫“Hand Game”。它在美国各地都有玩。有很多不同的名字。在中西部各州，它被称为“Up Chickens”，有时就叫“Jenkins”。好了，这就是答案，伙计们。我相信关于“Up Jenkins, Down Jenkins”还有更多信息，如果你们知道，请告诉我们。珍娜，你还记得在片场我教大家怎么玩吗？是的，我记得。你做了一个小教程，我很遗憾
once again angela martin does not participate i know you are our teacher but you are not a participant no well in the episode pam is the one who ends up having the quarter under her hand and Roy is doing the guessing. And he kind of looks at her and he's like, you know, not here to Stanley revealing that Pam has it. And then he says like, oh, I can just read you like a book. You can't keep anything from me. Oh, and Pam's like, oh, but I can. And I did.
安吉拉·马丁又一次没有参与。我知道你是我们的老师，但你不是参与者。不，嗯，在这一集中，帕姆最后手里拿着硬币，罗伊在猜。他看着她，说：“不在这里”，暗示帕姆拿着硬币。然后他说：“哦，我简直能看穿你。你什么都瞒不了我。”哦，帕姆说：“哦，但我能。而且我做到了。”
She just feels, I think, super guilty. She's on this track in this episode where she's trying to be more assertive. Remember, she went up to the bar and the bartender gave her the wrong drinks. Yeah. And she mustered up the courage to say, I'm sorry, one of these is supposed to be a light. And I really do think she meant it. And we'll get there when she's like, you know, I want us to have a real chance. And she sees Roy trying and she wants to try.
我觉得她感到非常内疚。在这一集中，她正试图变得更自信。记得吗？她走到吧台，酒保给了她错误的饮料。是的。她鼓起勇气说：“抱歉，其中一杯应该是淡啤酒。”我真的觉得她是认真的。我们会讲到她想说“我希望我们能有真正的机会”。她看到罗伊在努力，她也想努力。
And if this is going to work, then she wants all the cards on the table. Yeah. And part of this sort of being empowered to speak our mind is all just part of that. Well, now there's this little runner that happens at the bar that I love. It's so small, but it's these moments that just make the show for me where all of these kids walk in and they are introducing themselves to Creed. He says hi. He knows every single one of them. All of them. And then he's just got this quick little talking head where he's like, oh, yeah, I run a small fake ID company out of my car using a laminated. machine that I swiped from the sheriff's station. That's it.
如果这段关系要维持下去，她希望一切都摊开来说。是的。这种表达自己想法的赋权感，都是其中的一部分。嗯，现在酒吧里有一个我很喜欢的小插曲。虽然很短，但正是这些时刻让这部剧对我来说很特别，所有的孩子走进来，向克里德做自我介绍。他说“嗨”。他认识他们每一个人。所有的人。然后他有一个简短的采访，他说：“哦，是的，我用从警局偷来的塑封机在车里经营一家小型假证件公司。”就是这样。
That's how I know them. Why was I at the sheriff's station? How long have I been doing this business? It's clearly illegal. Well, listen, should we go back to David Wallace's house lady? Oh, yeah, because things are going off the rails. Oh, my God. It's amazing.
这就是我认识他们的原因。我为什么会在警局？我做这行多久了？这显然是非法的。好吧，听着，我们要回到大卫·华莱士家吗，女士？哦，是的，因为事情要失控了。天哪。太精彩了。
Well, Karen is continuing her prank on Jim, and they've had a conversation. with a couple, and she's like, oh, my gosh, did you see the way that woman was just staring daggers at me? I think it's because I dated her husband for a while while they were separated. Yeah. So she's keeping her joke going. Yeah. Dwight is still inspecting the house.
嗯，凯伦继续对吉姆恶作剧，他们和一对夫妇聊过天，她说：“天哪，你看到那个女人盯着我看的眼神了吗？我想是因为我曾和她丈夫约会过一段时间，当时他们分居了。”是的。所以她继续开着玩笑。是的。德怀特还在检查房子。
He's testing the smoke detector, the banister. I have to tell you, Dwight in this episode really reminds me a lot of a friend of mine who is a contractor, who's a comedian and also a contractor, which is a very funny combination. his name is Pete Holney. He's been in a ton of movies and things. He's very funny. But he would walk through my house and he would like bang on a wall and he'd be like, yeah, this can go. He's like, what? He'd thump a pillar. He'd be like, you can lose this. Like it's something else. He's like, yeah, you don't need that. I'm like, Pete, what is left of my house? Well, this reminds me a little bit of my dad because my dad is a builder, you know, and not professionally, he's an engineer, but he builds now. displays for the Children's Museum in St. Louis, this place called the Magic House. No, your dad is amazingly talented. He's amazingly talented.
他在测试烟雾探测器、扶手。我得告诉你，这一集里的德怀特真的让我想起我的一个朋友，他是个承包商，也是个喜剧演员，这组合很有趣。他叫皮特·霍尼。他演过很多电影。他很有趣。但他会走进我家，敲敲墙说：“是的，这个可以拆掉。”他就像，“什么？”他会敲敲柱子说：“这个可以去掉。”就像那是别的东西一样。他说：“是的，你不需要这个。”我说：“皮特，我房子还剩什么？”嗯，这让我想起我爸爸，因为我爸爸是个建筑师，你知道，不是职业的，他是工程师，但他现在为圣路易斯的儿童博物馆建造展品，那个地方叫“魔法屋”。不，你爸爸非常有才华。他非常有才华。
And by the way, can I say something about my dad that's sort of amazing? So my sister is a school teacher, and with the pandemic, their school opened. So they are doing in-person learning. And in order to make the space safer for the kids, especially the real little ones, who have a hard time keeping their masks on, like the preschool age. My dad built 30 Plexiglass screens for the preschool classes so that they could separate all the kids by these little screens. He just did that in his free time and delivered them all up to the school. He's amazing.
顺便说一句，我能说一件关于我爸爸的了不起的事吗？我妹妹是学校老师，疫情期间学校开放了。所以他们进行线下教学。为了让空间对孩子们更安全，特别是那些很难戴住口罩的小家伙，比如学龄前儿童，我爸爸为学前班做了30个有机玻璃屏风，这样他们就可以用这些小屏风把所有孩子隔开。他只是在业余时间做了这些，并把它们全部送到学校。他太棒了。
That is amazing. I know my sister Janet listens to our podcast and her and the other teachers made little screens using Legos and Plexiglass. They could have used your dad. he was so excited he had a whole template for it he had a whole little like assembly line he created but i could kind of see my dad like my dad because you know later in the episode dwight's like this was a great party he had a fantastic time like i think my dad's favorite time at a party would be if he could walk around and just like structurally examine a home yeah he doesn't need small talk he just needs a crawl space and a flashlight yeah and he might fix something that if you've
那太棒了。我知道我妹妹珍妮特听我们的播客，她和其他老师用乐高和有机玻璃做了小屏风。他们本可以用你爸爸的。他当时很兴奋，他有一个完整的模板，他创造了一条完整的小流水线，但我能想象我爸爸的样子，因为你知道在这一集后面，德怀特说“这是一个很棒的派对”，他玩得很开心，我觉得我爸爸在派对上最喜欢的时光就是如果他能四处走动，从结构上检查房子。是的，他不需要闲聊，他只需要一个爬行空间和手电筒。是的，他可能会修好一些东西，如果你有
got, like, a wonky doorknob that'll be fixed when he leaves. Oh, I love that. Well, Michael is very impressed by the vanilla candles. What a weird, like, foreshadow, right? For Jan's candle business? I know. He really, he really wants David Wallace to go to sandals with them. He's like, you would not believe how low this lady can go in the limbo.
比如一个摇晃的门把手，他走的时候就修好了。哦，我喜欢这个。嗯，迈克尔对香草蜡烛印象深刻。真是个奇怪的伏笔，对吧？为简的蜡烛生意？我知道。他真的很想让大卫·华莱士和他们一起去凉鞋度假村。他说：“你不会相信这个女士在凌波舞中能弯得多低。”
Jan is horrified. She's like, excuse us. And she pulls him into the bathroom. And then she starts just attacking him. Attacking him. Like, she's like, throw me up against the wall right here. Take me right here. And he's like, Jan, what do you stop getting undressed?
简吓坏了。她说：“失陪一下。”她把他拉进浴室。然后她开始攻击他。攻击他。她说：“把我推到墙上，就在这儿。就在这儿要我。”他说：“简，你干什么？别脱衣服了。”
This is inappropriate. And she goes, oh, I'm inappropriate. Get out of my way. She's, I mean, the woman is unhinged. it's so incredible because it really, it's like she's some sort of like a masochist or something, right? Like, she just, there's something in the humiliation that turns her on. Listen, she said this could go two ways. One is where she collapses into herself, like a dying star.
这不合适。她说：“哦，我不合适？滚开。”她，我的意思是，这个女人疯了。这太不可思议了，因为这真的就像她是某种受虐狂之类的，对吧？就像，羞辱中有什么东西让她兴奋。听着，她说这有两种可能。一种是她像一颗垂死的恒星一样向内坍塌。
It's like a self-fulfilling prophecy. She is just going to do this. that. Well, now we come up on one of my favorite scenes at the party. Is it Dwight wanting the rocking chair? Yes. We had a fan question from Megan Lou Chirony, who said, I read that David Wallace's son is played by Greg Daniels son, Owen Daniels. That is correct. That is true. It was so fun to have him on set. And, you know, it's just, it's so amazing now, Jenna, to see these kids as they're older. Talk about feeling old. Oh, my gosh. Owens like a, he's like a young man now, you know? It's crazy. I know, I know. The scene is just so good. And we had a fan catch from Nora A, Elijah Brown, and Ashley Dodd, who said this.
这就像一个自我实现的预言。她注定要这么做。嗯，现在我们来到了派对上我最喜欢的场景之一。是德怀特想要摇椅吗？是的。我们收到了梅根·卢·奇罗尼的粉丝提问，她说：“我读到大卫·华莱士的儿子是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯的儿子欧文·丹尼尔斯扮演的。”这是正确的。这是真的。让他来片场太有趣了。而且，你知道，现在看到这些孩子长大，真是太神奇了，珍娜。谈谈感觉自己老了。天哪。欧文现在像个年轻人了，你知道吗？太疯狂了。我知道，我知道。这一幕太棒了。我们收到了诺拉·A、以利亚·布朗和阿什利·多德的粉丝反馈，他们说：
In this episode, when Dwight is in David Wallace's son's room and he's sitting in the rocking chair, he asked the kid where it's from and says he wants one. In the final season, we can clearly see that Dwight got the same rocking chair. Get out! They must have saved it and put it at Shrew Farm. That's such a great tiny detail to catch. I am very impressed. I love that. That's amazing.
在这一集中，当德怀特在大卫·华莱士儿子的房间里坐在摇椅上时，他问孩子这是哪来的，并说他想要一个。在最后一季，我们可以清楚地看到德怀特得到了同样的摇椅。别开玩笑了！他们一定把它留下来并放在了施鲁特农场。这是一个非常棒的小细节。我印象深刻。我喜欢这个。太神奇了。
Well, then David Wallace asked Jim if he wants to go shoot hoops out back. Well, while they're playing basketball, they hear like, like a clamoring noise and they look up and there's Dwight on the flipping roof and he's like busted up part of the chimney. Yes, we got mail about this, Angela. Stephanie T. Phoebe B, Violet F, Abby M. and Iris Bell all wrote in to say, is rain really climbing on the roof when Dwight is inspecting the chimney? How did rain get on the roof? Because in previous podcast you mentioned that you guys had to ride a crane to get on the roof. So how did this work? Oh, good question. I didn't even think about that, but it looks like he's really up there. He's really up there, but the chimney is
嗯，然后大卫·华莱士问吉姆想不想去后院投篮。嗯，当他们打篮球时，他们听到像叮当声一样的噪音，他们抬头看，德怀特在翻屋顶，他把烟囱弄坏了。是的，我们收到了关于这个的邮件，安吉拉。斯蒂芬妮·T、菲比·B、维奥莱特·F、艾比·M和艾里斯·贝尔都写信问：雷恩在德怀特检查烟囱时真的在爬屋顶吗？雷恩是怎么上屋顶的？因为在之前的播客中你提到你们必须坐起重机才能上屋顶。所以这是怎么运作的？哦，好问题。我甚至没想过，但看起来他真的在上面。他真的在上面，但烟囱是
fake. Oh. Here is what Kentapedia told me. They had to build a chimney and rig it onto the roof of the house because where those guys were playing basketball, if you looked up at the roof, there was no chimney there. So that is a fake chimney. Rain had to climb on. Raine had to climb on. to the roof using a ladder, he was assisted by a stunt coordinator, and after he got on the roof, the stunt coordinator attached a little safety line to Rain's waist, fed it through his pant leg, so that in the event that he slipped, he wouldn't fall off the roof. So they had him like sort of like chained to the roof. He wouldn't fall off the roof, but he would get a horrendous wedgey. Yes. Yes. He'd get a wedge to it.
假的。哦。这就是肯特百科告诉我的。他们必须建造一个烟囱并把它安装在房子的屋顶上，因为在那些人打篮球的地方，如果你抬头看屋顶，那里没有烟囱。所以那是一个假烟囱。雷恩必须爬上去。雷恩必须爬上去。到屋顶上使用梯子，他在特技协调员的协助下，在他上屋顶后，特技协调员在雷恩的腰间系了一条小安全绳，穿过他的裤腿，这样万一他滑倒，他就不会从屋顶掉下来。所以他们让他像被锁在屋顶上一样。他不会从屋顶掉下来，但他会受到可怕的楔形挤压。是的。是的。他会受到楔形挤压。
End all wedgies. I cannot believe they built a fake chimney. Wow. That is so wild. Well, and then back inside the party, Angela, is a little couplet that I just love. And so did a lot of other people. I bet it happens at 16 minutes, 41 seconds. Is it, hi, Jan, not too good?
终极楔形挤压。我不敢相信他们造了一个假烟囱。哇。太狂野了。嗯，然后回到派对里面，安吉拉，有一段我非常喜欢的对话。很多人也喜欢。我打赌它发生在16分41秒。是“嗨，简，不太好吗？”
Hey, Jan, not too good. Yeah. Well, Alana Winkel, Rose Dowell, Julia Tyson, and Hannah Hawke all wrote in saying it was one of their favorite moments. And they love how there's this runner of Chan not responding correctly to the greeting that someone has given her. Yes, because we saw this in the initiation when Pam says hi and Jan goes, I'm great. Yes, exactly. Amazing. Well, Jenna, I love that couplet of dialogue, but I also loved Michael's talking head. I thought Paul, as the writer, knocked this out of the park because this is really how people talk, how they process information. Michael is saying, wow, you know, she really likes my potato salad. And I just bought it at the store. I wish I could make a potato salad like that. I mean, I guess it's really simple. It's potatoes and mayonnaise. There is something very wrong with Chan.
“嘿，简，不太好吗？”是的。嗯，阿拉娜·温克尔、罗斯·道尔、朱莉娅·泰森和汉娜·霍克都写信说这是他们最喜欢的时刻之一。他们喜欢简没有正确回应别人问候的这个梗。是的，因为我们在入职培训中看到过，当帕姆说“嗨”时，简说“我很好”。是的，完全正确。太棒了。嗯，珍娜，我喜欢那段对话，但我也喜欢迈克尔的采访。我觉得保罗作为编剧写得太棒了，因为这确实是人们说话的方式，他们处理信息的方式。迈克尔说：“哇，你知道，她真的很喜欢我的土豆沙拉。我刚在店里买的。我希望我也能做出那样的土豆沙拉。我的意思是，我想这很简单。就是土豆和蛋黄酱。”简有些地方非常不对劲。
Like, it does this pivot. But I feel like that's real life. I feel like that's how you, you're talking about something like, oh, yeah, there was such a, you know, a lovely breeze out today. And I don't think we can be married anymore. You're like, what? Well, let me tell you, I was completely distracted during this talking head, Angela, behind Steve's shoulder sitting at what looks like a vanity. Yeah. did you see it looks like it is a woman with really, really, really long blonde hair or something.
就像，它有一个转折。但我觉得这就是现实生活。我觉得这就是你，你在谈论一些事情，比如“哦，是的，今天微风真舒服。”然后“我不认为我们还能结婚了。”你会说“什么？”嗯，让我告诉你，我在这次采访中完全分心了，安吉拉，在史蒂夫肩膀后面，坐在看起来像梳妆台的地方。是的。你看到了吗？看起来像是一个留着非常非常非常长金发的女人之类的。
It looks like something out of like The Ring. Remember that horror movie The Ring? Yeah, wait. But with like blonde hair coming over her face or it's the back of her head. I was like, what? Who is? Oh, is that a person? Is it a wig on a stand?
看起来像《午夜凶铃》里的东西。记得那部恐怖电影《午夜凶铃》吗？是的，等等。但头发像金发一样垂在脸上，或者那是她的后脑勺。我当时想，什么？是谁？哦，那是个人吗？是支架上的假发吗？
what is the hairy object over his shoulder and I could never figure it out. No, I didn't catch it at all. I think I was so, like, riveted on Steve, but now I need to see it. Well, remember when we couldn't figure out what the weird fluffy thing was by Phyllis's desk and we figured out that it was a feather duster? Thanks to Cody. Cody knew immediately. Well, I don't know if we need to get Cody on this, but what is over Michael's shoulder during this talking head? someone tell me. It's around 16 minutes, 50 seconds, if anyone knows. Cody, we're going to move on, but could you take a look at it and weigh in? 16 minutes, 50 seconds. Well, while she's doing that, I feel like we should go back to poor Richards, Angela, because some shataki is about to go down. So much shataki and so quickly,
他肩膀上那个毛茸茸的东西是什么，我一直没弄明白。不，我根本没注意到。我想我当时太专注于史蒂夫了，但现在我需要看看它。嗯，还记得我们弄不明白菲利斯桌子旁边那个奇怪的毛茸茸的东西是什么，后来发现那是鸡毛掸子吗？多亏了科迪。科迪立刻就知道了。嗯，我不知道我们是否需要让科迪来处理这个，但在这次采访中迈克尔肩膀上的是什么？有人告诉我。大约在16分50秒，如果有人知道的话。科迪，我们要继续了，但你能看一眼并发表意见吗？16分50秒。嗯，当她在做那个的时候，我觉得我们应该回到理查兹酒吧，安吉拉，因为一些“shataki”要发生了。太多的“shataki”，而且发生得如此之快，
out of nowhere. Yeah. Should we talk about it? Yeah, I mean, Pam and Roy You're at the bar. Looks like it's been a pretty successful night. It definitely seems like Roy has had a few cocktails. He seems a little tipsy. And Pam says she wants to make a fresh start with him. No secrets. He says, me too. And then she says a month before their wedding at the casino night, her and Jim kissed. She says, I kissed Jim. And she said he had. you know, told her his feelings. And then Roy's like, wait, Jim came on to you? And she's like, listen. And he's like, I am listening. That's the problem. And he just goes from zero to 60. He throws a beer bottle or something at that mirror and it shatters. Yes. Yes. Well, I asked Kent about that because I remember that moment and I remember something happened there that wasn't supposed to happen. I was like, Kent, was that mirror meant to break?
毫无征兆。是的。我们要谈谈吗？是的，我的意思是，帕姆和罗伊在酒吧。看起来这是一个相当成功的夜晚。罗伊似乎喝了几杯鸡尾酒。他看起来有点醉了。帕姆说她想和他重新开始。没有秘密。他说：“我也是。”然后她说在婚礼前一个月在赌场之夜，她和吉姆接吻了。她说：“我吻了吉姆。”她说他告诉了她他的感受。然后罗伊说：“等等，吉姆勾引你？”她说：“听着。”他说：“我在听。这就是问题所在。”他瞬间从零加速到60。他扔了一个啤酒瓶之类的东西砸向那面镜子，镜子碎了。是的。是的。嗯，我问过肯特关于那个的事，因为我记得那一刻，我记得那里发生了一些不该发生的事情。我说：“肯特，那面镜子是故意要碎的吗？”
Because when I was watching the scene, I was like, what was the mishap with that mirror? So he said the glass mirror was a prop sign. It was rigged with safety glass and Roy was meant to hit it with his beer bottle and that all the bottles that Roy and Kenny are throwing are all made of candy. glass, but he checked the production report, and guess what it said? What did say? He said that in one of the takes, I got hit in the face with some of the candy glass when it, like, sprayed off of the mirror. So that was my memory.
因为当我在看那一幕时，我在想，那面镜子出了什么意外？所以他说玻璃镜子是一个道具标志。它装有安全玻璃，罗伊本应拿啤酒瓶砸它，罗伊和肯尼扔的所有瓶子都是用糖玻璃做的，但他检查了制作报告，猜猜上面写了什么？写了什么？他说在其中一个镜头中，当糖玻璃从镜子上溅开时，我的脸上被击中了。所以那是我的记忆。
It was like, something happened with that mirror. But he said, the production report said that I was fine and able to finish the day. So there you go. I kind of do remember, like, a little bit of a hullabaloo because some stuff flew in your face, like I kind of jog my memory. Well, and then, I mean, Pam was like, this is over. And he's like, it is over, you know? And he just starts wailing stuff at the wall. And out of nowhere, I mean, where the hell has kitty been? He just shows up and starts breaking shit. Yeah. Well, also, I don't know if you noticed at 18 minutes, 51 seconds, there is someone else in this scene
就像，那面镜子发生了一些事情。但他说是制作报告说我没事，能够完成那天的工作。所以就是这样。我确实记得有点骚动，因为有些东西飞到了你的脸上，就像我唤起了我的记忆。嗯，然后，我的意思是，帕姆说：“结束了。”他说：“结束了，你知道吗？”他开始把东西扔向墙壁。毫无征兆，我的意思是，基蒂去哪儿了？他突然出现并开始砸东西。是的。嗯，还有，我不知道你有没有注意到在18分51秒，这一幕里还有别人
and a number of people wrote in pointing it out. Kevin. Yes. Kevin, and doesn't he have his hands like clenched and little fists? Like he's ready to go just in case? Yes. Kimberly Willis, Heather R., Shannon R., Corey Haley, and Lauren Greenlee all said that when Roy starts the fight at the bar and he's yelling and throwing the glass in the lower left corner of the screen, you can see Kevin standing there, fists clenched, ready to defend Pam if Roy comes at her. It was such a sweet moment during a. a tough scene. Was this scripted? No. It was not in the script. Brian just improvised that, huh? I guess so. I think he did. It was a really great choice. Yeah. Yeah. Well, he's told Jim before he's got his
很多人写信指出了这一点。凯文。是的。凯文，他的手不是握成小拳头吗？就像他准备好以防万一一样？是的。金伯利·威利斯、希瑟·R、香农·R、科里·海利和劳伦·格林利都说，当罗伊在酒吧开始打架，他大喊大叫并扔玻璃杯时，在屏幕左下角，你可以看到凯文站在那里，握紧拳头，准备在罗伊冲向帕姆时保护她。在艰难的一幕中，这是一个如此甜蜜的时刻。这是剧本写的吗？不。剧本里没有。布莱恩只是即兴发挥了，是吗？我想是的。我想他做了。这是一个非常棒的选择。是的。是的。嗯，他之前告诉过吉姆他会支持他，
back, but let's hope it doesn't come to that. So that's, I think, Kevin being there for Pam and Brian just, that was part of his story that he had written for his character. Well, then we also got a really touching letter, Angela, from Paola Marquez, who says, I am grateful for that scene with Roy going violent at poor Richards and Pam's reaction to it. Many girls, me included, still believe that their partners' violent reactions are their own fault and that they must apologize for whatever triggered them that way. The first time I watched this episode and I saw Pam walking away from Roy stating that they were over was very remarkable for me. But it didn't make much sense to me.
但希望不会走到那一步。所以，我认为那是凯文在为帕姆着想，布莱恩只是，那是他为他的角色写的故事情节的一部分。嗯，然后我们还收到了一封非常感人的信，安吉拉，来自保拉·马尔克斯，她说：“我很感激罗伊在理查兹酒吧变得暴力以及帕姆对此的反应的那一幕。许多女孩，包括我，仍然认为伴侣的暴力反应是她们自己的错，她们必须为触发这种反应的任何事情道歉。我第一次看这一集，看到帕姆离开罗伊并声明他们结束了，这对我来说非常了不起。但这对我来说没什么意义。”
At first, I still thought that she had to calm him down, maybe apologize and work on their relationship. But after a while, I realized that it wasn't her responsibility and she was so right to stand up for herself and walk away from him. And Angie, I just want to say that it really means so much to me when women, young women, especially, find strength through Pam's story on this show. And I feel like it is a way that her story is impactful and it's just really meaningful to me in being the person who got to play Pam. I love that, and I'm so glad that that scene was able to resonate with her. Well, Jenna, I don't know if you caught, but there is a song playing under the whole scene while Pam and Roy are talking, and then it kind of crescendos as Roy and Kenny start smashing things. Yes.
起初，我仍然认为她必须让他冷静下来，也许道歉并努力修复他们的关系。但过了一会儿，我意识到这不是她的责任，她坚持自己的立场并离开他是完全正确的。安吉，我只想说，当女性，特别是年轻女性，通过帕姆在这部剧中的故事找到力量时，这对我来说意义重大。我觉得这是她的故事产生影响的一种方式，作为扮演帕姆的人，这对我来说真的很有意义。我喜欢这个，我很高兴那一幕能引起她的共鸣。嗯，珍娜，我不知道你有没有注意到，当帕姆和罗伊谈话时，整场戏下面有一首歌在播放，然后当罗伊和肯尼开始砸东西时，它变得越来越响。是的。
It is Carry On My Wayward Son by Kansas, which I thought was an interesting choice. Yes. Right? Well, the party has also ended. over at David Wallace's, and Michael and Jan are driving home, and, oh, this car ride. Oh, this is maybe one of my favorite scenes that I didn't know was a favorite scene until I watched it for this rewatch. I just can't get enough of Michael and Jan. They're such a hot mess, and they're so fun to watch.
那是堪萨斯乐队的《Carry On My Wayward Son》，我觉得这是一个有趣的选择。是的。对吧？嗯，大卫·华莱士家的派对也结束了，迈克尔和简开车回家，哦，这段车程。哦，这可能是我最喜欢的场景之一，直到我为了这次重看而看它之前，我不知道它是最喜欢的场景。我就是看不够迈克尔和简。他们是一团糟，看他们太有趣了。
And Malora is so good. You know, Jan is like, I feel sick. I just feel sick, and he's like, you didn't eat the potato salad, did you? You can't let that go. She's like, no, I just think it was a mistake to take our relationship public. It was so much more exciting when it was a secret. Michael is so hurt. Michael's like, I want it all, Jan.
马洛拉演得太好了。你知道，简说：“我觉得恶心。我只是觉得恶心。”他说：“你没吃土豆沙拉，对吧？”你不能放过那个。她说：“不，我只是觉得公开我们的关系是个错误。秘密的时候更令人兴奋。”迈克尔很受伤。迈克尔说：“我想要一切，简。”
I want the house and the kids and the picket fences and the ketchup bites and the tickling and the giggling. I know. And then this is when Malora's performance is one of my favorite things. She's like, you know what? I didn't mean it. I didn't mean it. I'm just tired. I didn't mean it, Michael. She's so good. She's so good. She's so good. And then, of course, out of nowhere, Dwight's like, you guys, don't break up. You're so good to get her. I did not remember that he was going to pop up at the end of that scene. It was great.
“我想要房子、孩子、栅栏、番茄酱、挠痒痒和咯咯笑。”我知道。然后这就是马洛拉的表演是我最喜欢的事情之一。她说：“你知道吗？我不是那个意思。我不是那个意思。我只是累了。我不是那个意思，迈克尔。”她演得太好了。她演得太好了。她演得太好了。然后，当然，毫无征兆，德怀特说：“你们，别分手。你们在一起真好。”我不记得他会在那一幕结束时突然出现。太棒了。
And you know what? They don't break up. Michael frames his love contract. That's in a deleted scene you don't see. You know, he thinks of it. As a love contract, he really does, and he frames it. He's so proud of it. It's just a letter to HR. That's all it is. Well, the episode ends with a pretty big cliffhanger. Yeah.
你知道吗？他们没有分手。迈克尔把他的爱情契约装裱起来了。那是在你没看到的删除场景里。你知道，他认为那是爱情契约，他真的这么认为，他把它装裱起来了。那只是一封给人力资源的信。仅此而已。嗯，这一集以一个相当大的悬念结束。是的。
And we don't do a ton of cliffhangers on this show, but this is one. Roy is sitting outside in the parking lot of poor Richards. Kenny comes out. He explains that he paid off. the bar with the jet ski money, so they won't call the cops. And then Roy says, I'm going to kill Jim Helper. Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
我们在这部剧里不做太多的悬念，但这是一个。罗伊坐在理查兹酒吧的停车场外面。肯尼出来了。他解释说他用摩托艇的钱付清了酒吧的账，所以他们不会报警。然后罗伊说：“我要杀了吉姆·哈珀。”天哪。天哪。
Yeah. This is kind of big for our show, because we never have a button like this. No, no. And we'll get to it next week. But boy, how we open. the next week. Yeah. Well, we had a fan catch here in this little scene in the parking lot. Max Better Vizzleberg said, we see a car parked outside of Poor Richards with the license plate, C.H.T. 8635. We have seen this license plate elsewhere, but it's always associated with Meredith's
是的。这对我们的剧来说有点大，因为我们从来没有这样的结尾。不，不。我们下周会讲到。但天哪，我们下周怎么开场。是的。嗯，我们在停车场这一小段戏里有一个粉丝发现。马克斯·贝特·维泽尔伯格说，我们看到理查兹酒吧外停着一辆车，车牌是C.H.T. 8635。我们在其他地方见过这个车牌，但它总是和梅雷迪思的
van. And Creed's Cadillac has this same license plate in the episode Gossip. What is the story with this license plate. Oh, what a good catch. You guys are so good. Clearly, it's a license plate we had cleared and we just kept putting it on different cars. Am I right? Yes. They had a few of these Pennsylvania license plates. And, you know, if we had a scene where a couple characters had to be walking down the street, we would park a couple of cars and just slap these approved license plates on them. And there weren't a ton of them. And so they just went on whatever car was visible. And they were not counting on Max Better to keep track. They were not, but he did. Well, guys, that was cocktails. We'll be back next week with the negotiation and special guest, David Denman. Oh, David
货车联系在一起。在《八卦》那一集中，克里德的凯迪拉克也有这个车牌。这个车牌有什么故事？哦，真是个好发现。你们太棒了。显然，这是一个我们清理过的车牌，我们只是不断把它放在不同的车上。我说得对吗？是的。他们有几个这样的宾夕法尼亚车牌。而且，你知道，如果我们有一场戏需要几个角色走在街上，我们会停几辆车，然后把这些批准的车牌贴在上面。而且数量不多。所以它们就贴在任何可见的车上。他们没指望马克斯·贝特会跟踪。他们没指望，但他做到了。嗯，伙计们，那是鸡尾酒。我们下周会带着《谈判》和特邀嘉宾大卫·丹曼回来。哦，大卫
Dinman's going to be there. Angela Martin might be titillated. Oh, she is. She is. But guys, before we go, Cody is weighing in on that background catch at 16 minutes, 50 seconds, and she says it literally looks like a person with a yellow blanket over them. It is so weird. Wait, can I see it? Cody, can you show it to us? What is that? That's so weird. Right? It's super creepy creep. David Wallace's house is haunted.
丹曼要来了。安吉拉·马丁可能会很兴奋。哦，她是。她是。但伙计们，在我们走之前，科迪正在权衡16分50秒的背景发现，她说它看起来确实像一个人身上盖着黄色的毯子。太奇怪了。等等，我能看看吗？科迪，你能给我们看看吗？那是什么？太奇怪了。对吧？超级令人毛骨悚然。大卫·华莱士的房子闹鬼了。
All right. That is the biggest takeaway from today's episode, everyone. But listen, we'll put it all up on Office Ladies' pod. You can decide who this creeper is in the background of Michael's talking head. All right, you guys, we hope you have a great week, and we'll see you next week. Love you. Bye. Love you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
好了。那是今天这一集最大的收获，大家。但听着，我们会把它全部放在“办公室女士”播客上。你们可以决定迈克尔采访背景里的这个潜伏者是谁。好了，伙计们，我们希望你们有一个愉快的一周，我们下周见。爱你们。再见。爱你们。感谢收听“办公室女士”的第二杯。
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela. Mackenzie. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。“办公室女士”是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·朱金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。“办公室女士”由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。